[Musik]
zdf heute live herzlich willkommen
was beschließen bund und länder heute
noch wissen wir es nicht noch tagen die
ministerpräsidentinnen und die
bundeskanzlerin aber im moment sieht es
danach aus als würde der shutdown noch
einmal verlängert was macht das mit uns
wie sehr belastet dass unsere psyche
darüber reden wir im lauf der sendungen
mit einer resilienz forscherin
wir sehen das bild aus berlin die
pressekonferenz hat noch nicht begonnen
wir sehen wartende kollegen und werden
wahrscheinlich gemeinsam noch eine weile
warten müssen
aber seien sie versichert sobald es
losgeht in berlin gehen wir natürlich
live drauf
erst mal aber reden wir mit unserer
hauptstadt korrespondentin in berlin
nicole diekmann zugeschaltet von dort
nicole das ist nicht das erste mal dass
wir das in dieser konstellation machen
ich habe gar nicht mitgezählt wie viele
dieser bund länder pks in den letzten
monaten schon gegeben hat was erwartest
du von heute abend wie was was hörst du
aus der runde wie kontrovers mit da
gerade debattiert oder wie einig ist man
sich denn vielleicht auch schon ja
anscheinend überraschend wenig
kontrovers das ist ne news die ich hier
mal gleich zu beginn weitergeben kann
was wir gerade aus dem kanzleramt hören
ist nämlich man rechnet noch mit ein bis
anderthalb stunden das wäre also halb 77
bis dahin will man fertig sein und das
ist tatsächlich überraschend wenn man
sich anguckt was da auf den tisch legt
wieder an themen unter anderem schule
das war ja so mit der dickste brocken
beim letzten treffen dieser art aber man
schreitet da jetzt doch ziemlich schnell
voran und in welche richtung könnte es
gehen gibt es da auch schon irgendwie
sachen die man hört ja es gibt erste
signale wir arbeiten ja es ist ja auch
schon teil des rituals immer mit diesen
so genannten beschluss verlagen die ein
bis zwei tage vorher kommt so der erste
entwurf auch bei uns journalistinnen an
da gibt es also auch großes interesse
von seiten der politik einzelner politik
erinnern dass wir da vorher schon mal
reingucken
denn das gehört natürlich auch zum spiel
dadurch wird die debatte ja nochmal
angefacht und die jetzige
beschlussvorlage die entscheidet sie
schon von der die wir gestern abend
bekamen und zwar in einem punkt in der
ursprünglichen stand der shutter und
geht bis zum x-ten das wurde dann im
laufe des heutigen vormittages
umgewandelt in den 14
märz und jetzt steht dort wohl der
siebte märz das bedeutet nicht dass
danach alles wieder ist wie vorher
sondern dass man vorher wieder
zusammenkommt ich glaube im moment ist
auf dem markt der dritte märz fürs
nächste treffen um dann weiter zu gucken
wie ist die lage müssen wir dann
vielleicht noch mal verlängern müssen
wir können wir lockern oder müssen wir
nochmal an der einen oder anderen
stellschraube drehen dass es eine und
das zweite ist die friseure die
friseursalons
da scheint es ja großen bedarf zu geben
da auch schon mal da auf jeden fall
schon mal zu lockern und da wir sprechen
sich jetzt die meldung ich habe hier ein
papier liegen das ist das aktuellste da
steht nun 22 februar drin das war auch
mal anders geplant erster märz jetzt
gibt es aber wieder nachrichtenagenturen
die melden was anderes also da ist noch
viel im schwange aber es sieht jetzt
sehr danach aus nach dem siebten märz
das ist jetzt erstmal das datum zu dem
man sich handelt und ist aber natürlich
auch noch nicht in stein gemeißelt noch
sitzt da ja niemand auf diesen plätzen
und sagt so ist es und nicht anders was
aber festzustehen scheint liebe nicole
ist dass es erst noch mal weiter geht in
eine verlängerung des lok downs denn das
ist ja was was in jeder dieser
beschlussvorlage irgendwie mehr oder
minder drin gestanden
also mehr als minder ich würde die
chance gerade gerne mal nutzen schon mal
zu erzählen was denn die userinnen und
user so schreiben wenn sie das hören
dass es noch mal weiter geht in die
verlängerung des lockdown ihr schreibt
zum beispiel über youtube ein user
namens pm oeste freundin einfach mal in
den arm nehmen das vermisse ich am
meisten
sebastian knott schreibt über youtube
konzerte und partys vermisse ich am
meisten
daniel schwaab schreibt auch über
youtube das fitnessstudio fehlt mir und
einfach diese unbeschwertheit reisen zu
können wann und wohin man möchte und
ebenfalls auf youtube schreibt alexander
erreicht man das leben ist grau geworden
ich sehne mich nach dem leben nach
corona ist nervt nur noch
das ist natürlich genau der spagat den
diese politiker jetzt gehen müssen
zugucken wie bleiben wir auf der
sicheren seite und gleichzeitig wie
können wir den menschen eine perspektive
geben ganz genau das ist auch ein
stichwort das auch in diesen beschluss
papier in jeder fassung die wir bisher
hatten vorkommt und was ja auch im
vorfeld des heutigen treffens in der
debatte eine große rolle gespielt hat es
geht darum die stichworte sind pandemie
müdigkeit impfmüdigkeit solchen
phänomenen die wir alle kennen wir sind
alle genervt wir wollen alle gerne
wieder normal leben klar total
verständlich dem aber irgendwie noch ein
bisschen da noch bei zu drehen das noch
die die letzten meter quasi noch zu
schaffen
das ist ja ist ja marathon es wurde ja
von anfang an gesagt und das versucht
man eben damit und das könnte jetzt
einen großen teil der noch laufenden
beratungen ausmachen
wenigstens einen stufenplan heute
vorzulegen der also etwas in aussicht
stellt also der über das was zum
beispiel daniel günther von der cdu vor
dem letzten treffen schon ganz offen in
die kamera gesagt hat was die leute so
frustriert er damals gesagt wir können
uns nicht von treffen zu treffen handeln
und immer nur sagen jetzt verlängern wir
nochmal jetzt kommt diese maßnahmen
obendrauf dafür lockern wir eventuell an
dieser stelle sondern wir müssen
irgendwie versuchen einen langen
ausblick den leuten
zu zu geben um die eben auch dazu zu
motivieren sich dann nochmal weiter
zusammen zu reißen und noch mal auf ganz
ganz viel zu verzichten davon muss man
ausgehen dass das nachher ein großer
bestandteil in dieser pressekonferenz
sein wird denn ansonsten läuft man
wirklich gefahr die ja immer noch große
bereitschaft diese maßnahmen zu machen
die umfragen sind da ja deutlich dass
dann auf dauer zu riskieren
diese hoffnung auflockerungen die ist
natürlich bei allen vorhanden bei den
geschäftsleuten bei der kulturbranche
bei den restaurantbetreibern man könnte
endlos weitermachen aber bei einer
gruppe ganz besonders nämlich bei den
kindern und jugendlichen und deren
eltern die homeschooling machen wie ist
denn die perspektive beim thema schule
das ist total interessant das ist in
diesen in diesem papier
da bin ich sehr habe ich sehr
aufgehorcht beim lesen quasi da steht
nämlich darin dass die länder in
eigenregie entscheiden dürfen wann sie
die schulen wieder öffnen und auch die
kindergärten die faktor war das bisher
auch immer so das entscheiden die länder
auch in eigenregie aber wir erinnern uns
nach dem letzten treffen das war das war
sehr sehr massiv da saß noch kanzlerin
merkel markus söder und unser
regierender bürgermeister hier in berlin
michael müller der gleichzeitig auch
gerade der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
vorsetzt saßen noch auf ihren stühlen
und berichteten von großer einigkeit von
gemeinsam gefassten gefassten
beschlüssen unter anderem neben dem die
schulen erstmal geschlossen zu halten
und parallel dazu verkündete der baden
württembergische ministerpräsident
kretschmann also in seinem bundesland
würden die schulen jetzt schon wieder
eher geöffnet
mit so nem mit so einer klausel in dem
jetzigen papier die länder sind dafür
zuständig versucht man das natürlich
direkt einzufangen und zu sagen es gibt
keinen einigen beschluss den haben wir
gar nicht angestrebt sondern wir lassen
das in der hand
der länder die sollen entscheiden nach
den individuellen gegebenheiten nach
instanzen nach wahrscheinlich auch
besiedlungen gebiete besiedelt wie gut
kann man auseinanderziehen den
unterricht durch zum beispiel den
einsatz von mehr bussen von mehr bahnen
und so walter verschiebung von
unterricht bildung von kurorten et
cetera et cetera das müssen die
eigenständig entscheiden also um das
noch einmal zu sagen
damit schiebt man natürlich einer
diskussion die dann wieder in gang
kommen würde direkt den riegel vor
wenn man von anfang an gesagt nee wir
streben hier keine einigkeit an keine
bundesweiten beschlüsse in dieser frage
sondern das entscheiden die länder
jeweils für sich
dann schauen wir mal direkt in ein land
dass da heute schon weit vorgeprescht
ist genau in dem von dir gerade
genannten rahmen und das passt auch zu
dem wie es vorher schon andere länder
gemacht habe heute ist es sachsen nicht
baden württemberg sondern sachsen
ministerpräsident michael kretschmer
dort von der cdu hat angekündigt er
möchte schulen und kitas schon in der
kommenden woche öffnen und die frage
geben wir jetzt mal weiter von berlin
nach dresden zu meiner kollegin steffi
moritz steffi hallo nach dresden
danke dass du mit dabei ist
wie kann man sich das erklären warum
prescht der ministerpräsident dieses
bundeslandes schon so weit vorbei
wohlgemerkt einer inzidenz einer sieben
tage incidents von 75,8 ja warum precht
sachsen so weit vor ich glaube die
probleme liegen natürlich in fast allen
bundesländern gleich nämlich die nerven
liegen blank bei den eltern
mitte dezember haben die schulen
geschlossen weil sind jetzt zwei monate
dass die kinder zuhause sind die
doppelbelastung in den familien
mitarbeit homeschooling home office das
ist einfach zu viel und zumindest nach
zwei monaten irgendwo ist man an dem
schritt angekommen wo man auch den
eltern eine perspektive geben muss wo
man kindern eine perspektive geben muss
es ist ja nicht nur ja sag ich mal die
die verlorene bildungs ebene bei den
kindern es gibt ja ganz viele andere
ebenen wo es verluste bei den kindern
gibt viele schwarze flecken die in der
biografie auftauchen könnte
jugendvereine beschweren sich
kindesmisshandlungen würden zunehmen
sagen kinderärzte als es gibt viele
viele punkte die hier mit eingeflossen
sind sicherlich in dieser entscheidung
das hat sich sachsen nicht leicht
gemacht das war aber schon immer klar
dass kitas und schulen die ersten sein
werden die in sachsen öffnen sollen dem
hat man jetzt entsprochen am montag soll
es also losgehen kitas und grundschulen
allerdings ist es erst mal nur
angekündigt muss man dazusagen am
freitag wird das sächsische kabinett es
beschließen oder willis beschließen
aber man hat gesagt schulen und kitas
grundschulen und kitas sollen öffnen
aber die schulbesuchs pflicht ist
ausgesetzt das heißt es bleibt den
eltern überlassen ob sie ihre kinder in
die schule schicken oder ob sie
weiterhin zu hause beim homeschooling
bleiben wollen es ist ihnen also
freigestellt weil die kitas genau das
gleiche ich kann die kinder zu hause
lassen ich kann sie auch in die
betreuung geben all das stößt natürlich
auf ein sehr geteiltes echo die gew die
gewerkschaft der lehrer und erzieher
kritisiert dies umfassend und gründlich
und sagt es ist also völlig grundlos so
schnell vorzupreschen und es wäre ein
überbietungswettbewerb wo sachsen hier
vorangehen will bei den eröffnungen aber
letzten endes ist es natürlich so dass
die eltern einfach wollen dass ihre
kinder wieder unter gleichaltrigen sind
ja aber sie kritisieren trotzdem auch
das wahrscheinlich die hygienemaßnahmen
nicht auf dem stand sein werden wie sie
von lehrern von erziehern und auch von
eltern erwartet werden wenn ich daran
denke im november war es so dass ja
sorry ich wollte nur ganz kurz du
sprichst hier mit vielen den vielen
leuten aus der seele das geht natürlich
nicht nur in sachsen den den eltern so
sondern hier schreibt zum beispiel über
youtube spot sb punkt ich vermisse den
kindergarten und die damit verbundenen
kontakte für meine
für meine tochter so sehr also das ist
genau das was eltern und kinder eben am
meisten vermissen dass die soziale
kontakte in diesen zeiten nicht haben
wie ist denn das bundesland sachsen
überhaupt aufgestellt im distanz
unterricht im wechsel unterricht und wie
können denn die lehrkräfte damit umgehen
dass sie dann plötzlich unterrichts
formate machen müssen für kinder die in
der schule sind für kinder die in der
not betreuungsgruppe sind und für kinder
die zu hause sind klappt das überhaupt
na ja wir reden hier nicht von wechsel
unterricht das geht ja um die
grundschulen und da hat sachsen ein
eigenes prinzip nämlich dass man in
festen klassenverbänden unterrichtet das
hat eigentlich auch ganz gut geklappt
das ist das gleiche wie im letzten jahr
man bleibt der festen klassen man
begegnet sich nicht in der schule
man begegnet sich nicht in der schule
auf dem schulhof auf den fluren also das
klappt eigentlich alles ganz anders
stellt sich noch immer das ressort
wieder zusammenspielen er die ganze
klasse also wenn du sagst eine
geschlossene klasse aber das heißt die
ganze klasse also 20 bis 25 kinder
kommen in der gruppe ehrlich
kleingruppen von fünf oder sechs wie das
zum beispiel in rheinland-pfalz gemacht
wird sondern 25 kinder in auf 25 kinder
ist bleibt die klasse als fester verband
bestehen
da hat man stufen möglichkeiten gefunden
man kommt unterschiedlich man geht
unterschiedlich man hat so genannte
peace and go zone vor der schule für die
eltern errichtet aber wie gesagt wenn
die kinder am nachmittag im hort sind
spielen sie zusammen
es wird gesagt diese klassenverbände
sollten wir da auch im hort bestehen
bleiben aber das ist vom personalaufwand
der lehrer und erzieher überhaupt nicht
zu schaffen das ist unmöglich
es spielt ja auch noch eine weitere
komponente mit weshalb auch die lehrer
und die erzieher diese diese
öffnungsklausel jetzt kritisieren wir
haben hier ein sehr hohes
infektionsgeschehen an der tschechischen
grenze ja gerade heute wurde bekannt
dass im dreiländereck polen tschechien
deutschland schon 60 prozent die
britische yukos mutation die so
ursächlich ist für die korona erkrankung
und deshalb besteht hier natürlich eine
große große angst der weg ist nicht weit
vom dreiländereck über ganz sachsen sich
auszuweiten
dass dies auch hier die vorherrschende
mutation sein könnte und das kaum haben
die schulen geöffnet dann vielleicht
zwei drei wochen später diese wieder
schließen müssen
denn das behält sich natürlich die
landesregierung vor sollten
die zahlen wieder steigen werden die
schulen wieder geschlossen wir sind auf
einem guten weg gesagt dass für 76 76
ist die zahl der incidents wir haben
inzwischen in den städten leipzig
dresden und chemnitz in der instanz von
50 beziehungsweise 52 das klingt alles
gut aber will vielleicht wie in die kol
vorhin sagte wäre es auch gut nach zwei
wochen durchzuhalten auch wenn das herz
die seele die emotionen alles aus einem
heraussprudeln und sagen bitte bitte
lassen normales leben in ganz kleinen
zügen wieder zu und auch ich wäre froh
wenn mein jüngster wieder in die
grundschule gehen könnte aber es wäre
umso schlimmer wenn nur kurze zeit
später alles wieder zu machen müsste mit
unabsehbaren folgen
steffi genau das schreiben auch viele
user yoga oder schreibt zum beispiel
über youtube genau das müssen die den
infektionsherd schule wieder öffnen dann
steigen die infektionszahlen ruckzuck
wieder nach oben und dann heißt es
wieder vier monate lockdown also das
bewegt nicht nur die sachsen sondern
auch hier viele user im chat erstmal bis
dahin vielen dank liebe steffi nach
dresden für diese einschätzung und wir
sind gespannt wie sich dann sachsen
tatsächlich entscheidet und vor allem
wie sich die situation dort entwickelt
und wir werfen noch mal gemeinsam einen
blick in den saal im bundeskanzleramt
ich wusste auch schon mal die raum
nummer von diesem von diesem
pressekonferenz aber heute weiß ich sie
nicht egal das ist ein hör ich gerade
aus der regie wir sehen aber nach wie
vor das in diesem saal überhaupt nichts
passiert wir erwarten nach wie vor
darauf dass angela merkel und berlins
regierender bürgermeister müller und der
bayerische ministerpräsident söder dort
vor die presse treten werden in ihren
funktionen als vorsitzender
beziehungsweise vize vorsitzende der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz ein großes
thema dort wird sein wie geht es weiter
mit den schulen und steffen moritz hat
gerade angesprochen
es kommt auch darauf an wie man
überhaupt aufgestellt ist digital und in
den möglichkeiten zu hause beim thema
homeschooling und dazu wollen wir uns
anschauen wie das in saarbrücken
funktioniert
verena garrett schildert die situation
dort für übungen für die schule teilen
sich massa und riad ein handy auf dem
kleinen bildschirm mathe machen
oft muss auch ihr vater unterstützen
nicht ganz einfach macht der computer
aber ist bei dem zwei hits finanziell
nicht drin wie so vieles nicht die
syrische familie lebt von hartz 4 5
tonnen sie oft 70 quadratmetern dazu
noch die sprachbarriere
eltern und kinder sind mit der situation
überfordert ist kann sich kummer mit
dieser sprache
laut einer aktuellen studie zeigt ein
jahr nach beginn der pandemie fast jedes
dritte kind in deutschland psychische
auffälligkeiten
besonders belastet durch die kontakt
beschränkungen sind kinder aus sozial
schwachen familien niedergeschlagenheit
und kopf und bauchschmerzen stiegen um
jeweils zirka zehn prozentpunkte und
haben sich im vergleich zur zeit vor der
pandemie damit fast verdoppelt kinder
aus familien mit wenig einkommen während
massa bekommen unterstützung im
kinderhaus mal statt
bei vielen von ihnen dass die schule die
einzige struktur die gegeben ist und
auch die fällt gerade weg fatal für
diese kinder sagt der leiter der
einrichtung es gibt kein klares konzept
wie diese katastrophe oder diese sehr
schwierige situation für viele viele
schüler in irgendeiner art und weise zu
lösen ist kuriert und massa bedeuten die
nachmittage im kinderhaus ein bisschen
halt in einer schwierigen zeit
da nicole damit sind wir wieder bei dir
in berlin und bei der frage nach dem
thema schulen und wenn ich dann noch mal
in diesem entwurf gucke der uns hier
auch vorliegt da steht auch noch mal
drin öffnungen betreuungs und
bildungsbereich haben priorität
medizinische masken lüften und
hygienemaßnahmen werden weiterhin nötig
seien irgendwie flippt man ja schon ein
bisschen aus wenn man nach zehn monaten
papier sieht in dem es immer noch um
masken lüften und hygienemaßnahmen geht
er ist denn da heute abend irgendwie zu
erwarten dass es kreative lösungen gibt
oder ist das zu viel
naja ich glaube nicht dass man so ein
papier jetzt so schreibt um noch
überraschungen lüften zu können bei der
anschließenden pressekonferenz also dann
stünde vielleicht mal ein bisschen mehr
darüber drin und ich erinnere an eine
veranstaltung vor zwei tagen am montag
von der bundesbildungsministerin anja
karliczek die hatte sich tatsächlich in
einem relativ großen stil versammelt mit
mehreren wissenschaftler/innen die alle
digital zugeschaltet waren in ihrer
pressekonferenz und hatte angekündigt
ein papier vorzulegen gestützt auf das
hat sie betont 40 internationale studien
interdisziplinär erarbeitet und anhand
dieses leitfadens so sagte sie könnten
sich die verantwortlichen in den schulen
jetzt vielleicht besser durch diese
pandemie hangeln und bessere
entscheidungen treffen und du sagst
gerade das stichwort ausflippen und
genau das hat einen direktor getan den
ich dann zu diesem papier interviewt
habe hier in berlin
er hat gesagt das ist überflüssig wie
ein kropf dieses papier und was
tatsächlich in diesem papier stand war
zusammengefasst das was auch in diesem
papier stand also nochmal die
bundesbildungsministerin schweres wort
gestützt auf internationale studien in
zusammenarbeit mit namhaften mehreren
wissenschaftler/innen stellte dann diese
studie vor und im grunde sagt die
gruppen bilden lüften luftfilter
aufstellen naja sind wir zu keiner
einigung gekommen kann man machen kann
man auch lassen und masken tragen
mehr war da nicht und bitte nicht singen
und draußen sport machen das habe ich
auch noch in erinnerung
also wir haben ja noch gar nicht über
den themenkomplex universitäten
gesprochen ich erinnere mich dass es ja
auch zu begrüßen schon gesagt ich sitze
als auch nicht zum ersten mal hier ich
habe ja schon ein paar ministerpräsident
in den konferenzen von hier aus dann
quasi begleitet und immer wieder taucht
bei den userinnen auch die frage auf wie
ist das an den unis hat irgendjemand
über die unis gesprochen und das ist
tatsächlich bei diesen pressekonferenzen
auch überhaupt noch nicht passiert also
ich kann genau dazu steigt also genau
auch heute jetzt wieder kommt die frage
heute von anni wolf ich vermisse es im
hörsaal zu sitzen und echte menschen zu
sehen und mit ihnen zu sprechen ich
hatte ein semester normalen
studentenalltag und seitdem alles nur
noch online
aber du sagst auch heute in diesem
papier ist dazu nichts zu finden
also es wäre eine große überraschung
wenn jetzt tatsächlich konkrete konkrete
fahrpläne für die schulen also auch in
der praktischen ausgestaltung im
unterricht was über lüften hinausgeht
wir haben hier in berlin im moment
glaube ich - sechs grad anderswo in der
republik ist es jetzt auch nicht viel
werben
damit ist ehrlich gesagt nicht zu
rechnen es wäre schön wenn aber meine
kristallkugel und meine erfahrung sagen
mir eher nicht was betrifft denn die
anderen branchen also es geht ja auch
friseure hast du schon angesprochen ganz
aber vielleicht für die die jetzt dazu
gekommen nochmal erwähnen was da geplant
ist
der einzelhandel das handwerk die die
gastronomie die kulturszene aldi blicken
ja auch wieder auf diesen termin heute
was gibt es denn da zu erwarten
genau ich sage noch mal schnell was zu
den friseursalons da sieht es sehr
danach aus als gäbe es tatsächlich
demnächst also in naher zukunft doch
eine öffnung
das begründet man damit dass man das als
friseurbetriebe als hygienisch
notwendige körpernah dienstleister
betrachtet und entweder dagegen die
zahlen jetzt noch ein bisschen
durcheinander werden die schon zum 22
februar geöffnet das ist ja tatsächlich
schon sehr bald in zwölf tagen wäre das
oder aber der andere termin der hier so
durch das regierungsviertel war bat das
wäre der erste mehr als ja auch nicht
mehr so weit bis dahin
und was die restlichen betriebe angeht
gastronomie einzelhandel und so weiter
da ist dieses papier noch relativ weich
also da müssen wir tatsächlich noch
warten es gab mal in der
ursprungsversion den vorschlag entweder
abhängig von einem datum oder abhängig
von einer inzidenz zahl bundesweit dann
da über lockerungen nachzudenken zum
beispiel für geschäfte dann aber wieder
mit beschränkungen die kennen das ja
schon 20 quadratmeter je kunde kundinnen
und so weiter aber da werde ich aus
diesem papier noch nicht so schlau
daraus ob das heute hier konkret
wirklich in der konnte in der
pressekonferenz schon vorgestellt werden
wird
dann warten wir es mal ab wenn du recht
behält und das war jetzt schon oft der
fall dann könnte es ja tatsächlich
ungefähr in der guten halben stunde
dreiviertelstunde schon so weit sein
dass wir mehr sind wissen aber wir
warten es ab ich habe übrigens in der
zwischenzeit mit hilfe der redaktion
hier noch mal nachgeguckt und wir können
vielleicht mal kurz auf meinem desktop
hier schalten so oft haben bund und
länder bisher beschlüsse gefasst zdf
heute hat das zusammengefasst und es
sind 21 gipfel wenn ich das jetzt hier
richtig gezählt habe und der erste davon
war am 12
dritten das heißt wir sind also fast
schon bei einem ganzen jahr die uns
diese treffen beschäftigen und diese
pandemie nicole vieles hatten diese
treffen gemeinsam lieber meistens
digital ich erinnere mich im sommer
waren sie mal kurz oder es gab ein oder
zwei die dann tatsächlich auch im
präsenz stattgefunden haben und was für
mich aber heute tatsächlich neu ist dass
ich das gefühl habe es gibt so gut wie
keine verlässliche zahlen grundlage für
diesen gipfel denn man hat zwar die
inzidenz aber man hat noch überhaupt
keine richtigen aussagen darüber was
diese mutation im hintergrund für eine
welle
schlägt und vielleicht gerade auf eine
dritte welle zuläuft kannst du dazu mal
was sagen und auch welche rolle die
mutation überhaupt in dieser diskussion
spielt weil ich finde in dem paper zwar
ganz in der einleitung das wort mutation
aber danach taucht es nicht mehr auf
genau so ist es und es kommt ja relativ
früh in der einleitung ist genau da
sonst ich sag's mal einmal in die kamera
da wird sich bedankt für das bisherige
durchhalten und da taucht schon das wort
mutanten auf oder mutationen
das ist auch eine art paradigmenwechsel
heute womöglich denn bisher hat man sich
immer auf die zahlen gestützt in der
argumentation auf die incidents offen er
wert auf die auslastung der
intensivbetten usw
jetzt geht es um die mögliche rasante
ausbreitung vor allem der britischen und
auch der südafrikanischen variante des
corona virus und da gibt es jetzt also
zwei lager es gibt einmal das lager das
ist da ist angela merkel ja immer sehr
klar dass sehr vorsichtige lager oder
auch karl lauterbach von der spd das
sind diejenigen die sagen das ist so
hoch ansteckend wir sehen das ja schon
in den anderen ländern wie zum beispiel
großbritannien
dass wir jetzt noch vorsichtig sein
müssen auch wenn die zahlen
kontinuierlich zurückgehen und einzelne
einzelne landkreise sich wirklich der 50
schon eher ja wir dürfen jetzt nicht
lockern weil die gefahr eben das
drohende aus brighton dieser mutationen
das muss uns vorsichtig stimmen auf der
anderen seite das ist mit ein
hauptargument zum beispiel der fdp zu
sagen man kann so nicht weitermachen
da ist das argument es gibt keine
verlässlichen zahlen es gibt keine
wissenschaftliche grundlage dafür und
nur aufgrund einer befürchtung die sich
eben nicht festmachen lässt anhand von
zahlen jetzt weiterhin diesen harten
kurs zu fahren
dafür sehen wir keine grundlage das
spielt eine zentrale rolle bei diesem
treffen heute klar die user schreiben
auch zum beispiel ihren schönen auch
über youtube was wenn es wieder zu früh
ist
mit fehlenden impfungen und neue
mutationen unter facebook schreibt
alfred haben alles zu lassen bis wir
eine incident von null haben und gut ist
lieber ein schrecken mit ende als ein
schrecken ohne ende
die forderung zero gravity hören wir ja
auch von verschiedenen seiten kann man
sagen welche ministerpräsidentinnen sich
da welche schule zuordnen lassen kann
man das irgendwie ordnen
wer da er sagt wir müssen jetzt eher
lockern weil in abwägung all dessen was
uns vorliegt müssen wir die leute
irgendwie wieder mal untereinander
lassen und wer sagt nein wir bleiben
konsequent und lassen so lange wie es
geht so viel wie möglich zu naja es ist
eigentlich die alte konfliktlinie ich
nenne mal zum beispiel markus söder
bayerischer ministerpräsident gehört er
zu den ganz vorsichtigen aber ich gehöre
insofern auch zu den vorsichtigen als
ich weiß dass sich in solchen in solchen
sitzungen wie heute dann auch plötzlich
die stimmung ändern kann und sich dann
plötzlich ministerpräsidentin und doch
anders positionieren
deswegen wäre ich mit so etwas
vorsichtig zu sagen das ist lager und
das ist lager b was man aber sagen kann
ist das ja sowohl bodo ramelow
ministerpräsident in thüringen
linkspartei aber auch der
baden-württembergische ministerpräsident
von den grünen winfried kretschmann in
den vergangenen wochen sehr
selbstkritisch geäußert haben und gesagt
haben sie seien also teilweise hätten
sie falsch gelegen
mit ihren einschätzungen vor allem noch
im herbst als sie sich für lockerungen
ausgesprochen hätten also insgesamt ist
das bewusstsein schon da dass man es da
tatsächlich mit einer drohnen dritten
welle zu tun hat dann würde ich an
dieser stelle sagen nicole wir warten
mit dir gemeinsam weiter bis es in
berlin los geht wir schauen noch einmal
in den saal wo die pressekonferenz
stattfinden soll sehen weiterhin leere
stühle die kollegen lesen zeitungen also
es dauert noch ein bisschen und bis
dahin möchte ich gerne das gespräch
suchen mit frau professor besser die uns
zugeschaltet ist
schönen guten abend aus rheinland-pfalz
frau professor wässer sie sind
psychologen professorin für klinische
psychologie und neuropsychologie an der
uni in mainz und wir haben jetzt sehr
viel darüber gesprochen dass vieles noch
nicht möglich sein wird und dass dieser
shutdown in die verlängerung gehen wird
wir haben schon von vielen userinnen und
usern gehört welche dinge ihnen am
meisten fehlen
was ist aus ihrer sicht das schlimmste
was macht das mit uns wenn dieser
shutdown in die verlängerung geht ja
erst mal hallo nach mainz und ich glaube
dass tatsächlich schlimmste wenn wir in
der verlängerung gehen und es wird ja
unumgänglich sein dass wir eine
verlängerung gehen ist sind die sozialen
kontakte die sozialen kontakte sowohl
für die erwachsenen nicht zur arbeit
gehen zu können im home office zu
bleiben aber vor allen dingen eben auch
für die kinder und jugendlichen nicht in
die kita zu können und nicht in die
schule gehen zu können ich glaube dass
es das was am schwierigsten ist und auch
letztlich in der summe für viele
familien eine hohe belastung bedeutet
und die verlängerung wirklich einfach
vieles auf die probe stellt wie immer in
dieser sendung freuen wir uns über
fragen und kommentare und heute ganz
besonders schreibt uns gerne in die
chats über youtube und facebook und wenn
ihr die zdf- heute- app nutzt dann an
die eingeblendete e-mail-adresse und
schreibt uns wie es euch geht schreibt
uns was ihr am meisten vermisst schreibt
uns was euch am meisten fehlt und wir
haben diese frage genau aufgestellt in
münchen
und schau mal rein was die leute da
geantwortet haben und gt relativ gut da
gibt es gerade andere länder menschlich
sehr deutlich härter trifft also wenn
wir es nicht schaffen wir dann jetzt
lockerungen glaube ich bin nicht so viel
sinn machen aber es wird schon auch an
den nerven jetzt noch länger jetzt
ferien schon einschränken wenn man recht
wenig machen kann also so langsam jetzt
schon
man strengt irgendwo versteht man dass
es sein muss aber es wird auch immer
schwieriger ist weiter durchzuhalten vor
allem weil frau professor besser das
deckt sich auch mit dem was hier in den
kommentaren steht da schreibt jemand
über youtube da ich alleine lebe
vermisse ich soziale kontakte
ich bin 40 plus und fühle mich
inzwischen wieder wie ein kind weil es
irgendwie nur meine eltern und mich zu
geben scheint und jemand anders schreibt
auch zum thema einsamkeit hektar steak
in einsamkeit ist meist leicht auch
remote zu bewältigen oder zumindest
abzumildern sich gegenseitig zu besuchen
unternehmungen mit freunden und familien
sowie einfacher umarmungen fehlen jedoch
mittlerweile sehr was ist ihre
handreichung was wäre ihr hilfsangebot
für uns alle die wir unter dieser
situation leiden was kann man tun damit
man aus dieser isolation aus der
einsamkeit die hier gerade beschrieben
wurde
heraus kommen kann natürlich ist es so
dass wir nur ganz bedingt das jetzt im
moment uns holen können was wir
eigentlich am dringendsten bräuchten und
nach was wir uns auch sehnen und das
sind natürlich berührungen umarmungen
mit jemand auch eng zusammen zu sein zu
feiern
das ist nicht möglich aber ich glaube es
ist ganz wichtig sich alternativen zu
suchen sich zum beispiel auch auf
ungewöhnliche weise zu verabreden eben
remote auf den unterschiedlichsten
plattformen dinge zusammen zu tun aus
denen sich auch wirklich sehr
ungewöhnliche und sehr lustige
begegnungen entwickeln können und das
einfach zu nutzen um trotzdem schöne
momente zu erleben und dessen stück weit
zu ersetzen natürlich ist es nicht
vollständig ersetzt war aber wir müssen
wege finden um trotzdem da kreativ ein
bisschen raus zu kommen und uns eben
auch zu belohnen das ist auch ganz
wichtig so zusagen für den körper und
auch damit wir unserem gehirn die chance
geben tatsächlich auch die botenstoffe
frei zu setzen die wir auch freisetzen
wenn wir uns mit anderen tatsächlich
live treffen in präsenz haben sie
konkrete tipps konkrete tipps also hier
in der preis zum beispiel ist ein ganz
konkrete tipps des online weinproben
organisiert werden und das ist
eigentlich immer ein garant dafür dass
tatsächlich auch da lustige themen
aufkommen und man sich unterhält das man
auch immer themen hat über die man sich
unterhalten kann
ich kenne es zum beispiel auch dass
menschen sich live zum kochen verabreden
und dann gemeinsam auch tatsächlich
essen und ob man das jetzt tut gemeinsam
auch auf einer plattform oder ob man das
einfach in verbundenheit gemeinsam macht
ist glaube ich gar nicht so entscheidend
ich glaube man fühlt sich einfach diesen
menschen wieder näher und man hat auch
ein thema mit dem man dann über das man
dann zum beispiel danach sprechen kann
und erinnerungen gemeinsam teilen kann
und ich glaube das ist auch ein ganz
wichtiger punkt sich einfach erinnerung
zu schaffen die auch halten und über die
wir dann auch vielleicht wenn
hoffentlich die pandemie überstanden ist
sprechen können was wir vielleicht auch
in dieser zeit schönes gemacht haben und
großartiges gemacht haben nun ist es
natürlich immer auch eine frage von
energie die man aufbringen muss um sich
was einfallen zu lassen
und nun haben wir das ja alle nicht als
neue situation sondern wir erleben das
ja schon seit einem jahr
wir haben online weinproben gemacht wir
haben mit freunden telefoniert wir haben
spaziergänge an der frischen luft wieder
entdeckt es ist nur so dass alle jetzt
auch von diesen dingen tatsächlich die
schnauze voll haben und die luft raus
ist wie geht man damit um dass man aber
trotzdem weiß man hat immer noch eine
strecke die man vor sich liegen hat die
möglicherweise je nachdem welche vorlage
man nimmt bis zum 22
februar bis zum 17 märz je nachdem wo
welche schule oder welcher frisur und am
ende dann auch welches restaurant
aufmacht wie wie kann man das denn
strecken
also ich glaube das eine ist dass uns
eben auch bewusst sein müssen dass es
ganz normal ist dass wir ein stück weit
die nase voll hat das haben dass uns das
auf die nerven geht und dass wir auch
keine lust haben die dritte sprache zu
lernen und den keller noch mal umzubauen
und deswegen ist es glaube ich ganz
wichtig sich auch mal einfach am tag
gehen lassen zu können
um einfach nicht permanenten druck zu
unterliegen dass man immer weiter etwas
unternehmen muss um den tag zu fühlen
das ist es ein und das andere ist glaube
ich dass man auch da wieder auf die
soziale unterstützung zurückgreifen muss
sich gegenseitig sozusagen ein stück
weit raus zu holen wenn man merkt der
andere ist in so einer schwierigen und
vielleicht auch ein bisschen
lethargischen phase den daneben mit
rauszuholen und das genauso für seine
freunde zu tun und ich glaube durch
diese letztlich gemeinschaft und auch
die soziale unterstützung der wissen wir
dass das ein ganz wichtiger faktor ist
in der ganzen residenz eben der
widerstandskraft für die psychische
gesundheit die auch wirklich zu nutzen
und darauf sich ja auch ein stück weit
zu verlassen
viele menschen hören dass und versuchen
das anzuwenden viele menschen blicken
nach berlin auch heute abend wieder und
warten darauf dass die bundeskanzlerin
und die beiden vorsitzenden der
vorsitzende und der stellvertretende
vorsitzende der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz vor die
kameras treten
noch ist es nicht soweit möglicherweise
haben wir vorhin von nicole diekmann
gehört unserer hauptstadtkorrespondent
korrespondentin könnte es ab halb
ungefähr so weit sein
aber wir wissen es nicht und wir hoffen
dass es nicht allzu lange dauert frau
professor besser jemand der ihnen
zugehört hat schreibt gerade über
youtube mit dem namen zaunkönig sorry
aber soziale medien video chat et cetera
können das nicht mehr auf wiegen am
anfang hat es geholfen
aber die zeiten sind vorbei und auch die
ähnliche richtung schreibt tobias große
über facebook mal wieder zum fußball
gehen ob nun stadion oder selber spielen
mal was schönes mit den kindern
unternehmen auch mal zeit mit meiner
partnerin
ob essen gehen oder kino irgendwas und
daraus spricht ja diese verzweiflung die
viele familien erleben dass sie zwar
dankbar sind dafür dass sie einander
haben wenn man in einem guten sozialen
umfeld lebt über die andere reden wir
natürlich auch gleich noch ausführlich
aber man weiß ja gar nicht was man
machen soll man kann ja nirgendwo hin
und es ist genau natürlich das problem
und ich glaube es hilft uns aber in der
aktuellen situation letztlich nicht
immer nur zurückzublicken was wir
natürlich alles hatten und welche
möglichkeiten wir alle hatten und dass
wir die natürlich auch wieder haben
wollen das ist ganz selbstverständlich
aber ich glaube in der aktuellen
situation hilft tatsächlich nur auch ein
stück weit die akzeptanz dass wir gerade
im moment dann noch nicht viel ändern
können weil das problem ist je mehr wir
uns damit beschäftigen was wir lieber
tun würden dass du mehr verschwenden wir
eigentlich unsere energie und diese
energie haben wir dann nicht mehr um zb
uns zu überlegen was uns denn aus der
ganzen misere so ein bisschen raus
bringen kann es was uns aus der trägheit
herausführen kann und deswegen ist das
glaube ich ganz essenziell dass wir
versuchen ohne es einfach passiv
hinzunehmen aber versuchen wirklich die
situation zu akzeptieren weil keiner
kann uns tatsächlich klarheit bringen
bringen wird uns die klarheit letztlich
werden nur die zahlen und wir können
letztlich gar keine klare perspektive
bekommen es ist völlig klar dass wir die
bekommen wollen aber keiner kann sie uns
wirklich geben ohne uns vielleicht
hinterher zu enttäuschen
und deswegen glaube ich ist es einfach
ganz wichtig da ein stück weit die zähne
halt noch zusammenzubeißen und
vielleicht mit der energie die wir auf
sparen weil wir uns nicht die ganze zeit
mit nicht möglichen beschäftigen dann
irgendwie auch pläne zu schmieden wenn
wir es wieder tun können
dann würde ich gerne mal den blick auf
die kinder richten hier schreibt über
youtube detektive was richten
monatelange kontakt beschränkungen
schulausfälle und sport und
freizeitaktivitäten verbote bei kindern
an und inwiefern ist das noch
verhältnismäßig was ist ihre antwort
naja was es mit kindern anrichtet werden
wir leider wahrscheinlich erst in
einigen monaten vielleicht sogar ein
bisschen aber ich glaube ein ganz großes
problem ist tatsächlich dass wir den
kindern ganz viele möglichkeiten nehmen
sowohl in der schule aber vor allen
dingen auch in der freizeit in dem in
ihrem sport musik in vereinen den
organisationen in denen sie sich
wohlfühlen dann nehmen wir ihnen ganz
einfach die möglichkeit wichtige
positive erfahrung zu machen auch ganz
viel positive verstärkung zu bekommen
und letztlich dafür zu sorgen dass diese
kinder einfach eine selbstwirksamkeit
erfahren also glauben dass das was sie
tun wirklich wichtig ist und etwas
ändert an der situation und das
selbstbewusstsein bekommen und es
bekommen sie ganz häufig eben nicht oder
nicht nur in der familie
gerade kinder aus sozial schwächeren
familien sondern es bekommen sie in
vereinen indem sie an sport wettbewerben
teilnehmen indem sie die anerkennung von
ihren trainern die anerkennung von
mitspielern bekommen und sich dadurch
ganz einfach stolz führen und wir wissen
das aus jahrzehntelanger resilienz
forschung dass dieses ganz ganz wichtige
faktoren sind damit kinder eben auch
psychisch stark sind und ich glaube wir
können das natürlich nur bedingt jetzt
ändern wir können dabei einerseits
aufklären und andererseits auch ein auf
augenmerk danach darauf richten dass es
ganz besonders wichtig ist die kinder
wenn all dies wieder möglich ist auch
wirklich zu stärken
dazu schreibt auch über youtube liesel
gödecke die allergrößte sorge bereitet
mir die emotionale entwicklung unserer
kinder
die masken kein treffen mit freunden
keine umarmung von oma und opa was macht
das mit unseren kindern können sie
darauf vielleicht auch noch mal kurz
eingehen
ich glaube dass die masken tatsächlich
viel weniger ausmachen als wir das
glauben da gibt es auch schon ein paar
erste studien dazu ich glaube darüber
müssen wir uns weniger sorgen machen
aber natürlich ist die bindung zum
beispiel an die großeltern die geht
nicht verloren weil die bindung meist
sehr stark ist wenn die kinder die
großeltern auch früher wenn sie viel
kontakt hatten
aber natürlich vermissen beide seiten
den engen kontakt und beide seiten
sorgen sich auch dass sie ein stück weit
den kontakt verlieren
weil die kinder machen eine bestimmte
entwicklung durch und natürlich haben
großeltern angst dass sie diese
entwicklung auch ein stückweit verpassen
und dadurch die emotionale nähe ich
glaube ganz wichtig ist es da wirklich
auch von beiden seiten auch von den
eltern zu schauen dass der kontakt eben
nicht verloren geht weil großeltern eine
ganz wichtige rolle in der entwicklung
spielen und das andere dinge genutzt
werden wie zum beispiel auch mal ein
brief zu schreiben an die großeltern
auch zu versuchen anders über telefon
oder eben virtuelle meetings in kontakt
zu bleiben
das ist im moment das einzige was bleibt
aber ich glaube ganz wichtig all diese
dinge zu nutzen um für beide seiten eben
diese emotionale nähe auch zu
stabilisieren
nun habe ich eingangs viele kommentare
vorgelesen von leuten denen dem alltag
etwas fehlt und das erleben wir ja alle
wir alle haben sehnsucht nach vielen
dingen die wir im moment nicht machen
können es gibt aber auch menschen die
tatsächlich depressionen bekommen die
psychisch krank waren schon vor der
pandemie deren symptome sich jetzt
verstärken
bevor wir darauf jetzt explizit eingehen
können sie erklären woran man merkt dass
etwas einen umtreibt was uns alle im
moment umtreibt weil die situation
einfach eine fordernde ist und wo die
grenze liegt zu einer tatsächlich
pathologischen erscheinung mit der man
dann auch zum arzt gehen sollte oder
muss also ich glaube ganz wichtig ist es
dass man ein stück weit auch sich so ein
bisschen selbst beobachtet natürlich
nicht so sehr aber dass man selbst
schaut inwiefern hat man sich denn im
vergleich zu vor der pandemie vielleicht
verändert und zwar im vergleich zu
phasen in denen man durchaus auch
vielleicht besonders viel stress gehabt
hat oder belastungen erlebt hat und
einfach schaut hat sich das besonders
stark verändert ist es schlimmer und vor
allen dingen ganz wichtiger faktor ist
auch die zeit beobachte ich dass ich
wirklich über mehrere wochen hinweg
immer niedergeschlagen bin oder fast die
meiste zeit dass sich das interesse
verlieren tatsächlich an jetzt nicht
normalen aktivitäten weil wir die gar
nicht machen dürfen aber auch das
interesse anderer
anzurufen mit anderen in kontakt zu
treten dass ich mich ganz stark
zurückziehe verändert sich mein appetit
merke ich dass sich weniger gut schlafe
entweder ein schlafe oder permanent
aufwache und das sind alles anzeichen
die mission signal geben könnten dass es
gut wäre da doch professionelle hilfe
aufzusuchen einfach um das auch
abzuklären
und da ist aber eben ganz wichtig dass
es nicht für ein zwei tage weil ich
glaube das haben wir fast alle im moment
dass es zeiten gibt wo wir einfach auch
wirklich einen ganz schlechten tag haben
und eigentlich alles nervt und wir sehr
niedergeschlagen sind und auch träge
sind sondern es muss über einen zeitraum
von mindestens zwei wochen die meiste
zeit tatsächlich so sein
ein wort das im chat ganz oft zu lesen
es ist das wort depression ich möchte
gerne drei meinungen oder 3 kommentare
drei fragen hier mal einbringen crash co
fragt über youtube oder schreibt über
youtube als menschen mit depression muss
ich sagen dass es sehr schwierig ist in
dieser zeit man weiß dass maßnahmen sein
müssen aber andererseits geht man
physisch und psychisch vor allem
psychisch am stock auch über youtube
schreibt es an die funny wie es mir geht
scheiße arbeiten gehen darf ich arbeite
als medizinstudentin nebenbei in der
pflege und darf dort mit mehr als einem
haushalt zusammen sein aber wehe ich
gehe mit zwei kollegen mit denen ich
schicht hatte noch gemeinsam spazieren
mittlerweile bin ich so depressiv dass
ich nicht mehr weiter weiß
und auch über youtube schreibt sk ich
halte den lockt dann überhaupt nicht
mehr gut durch hatte vorher schon
depressionen die sich stark
verschlimmert haben würde so gern wieder
schwimmen gehen wenn sie das hören was
sagen sie dazu
ich glaube dass es tatsächlich für diese
menschen ganz ganz schwierig ist weil
ein ganz wichtiger ganz wichtige
maßnahme eben auch gegen depressive
symptome sind aktivitäten und ist es
wieder aufleben lassen von aktivitäten
um eben auch positive verstärkung zu
erfahren um tatsächlich überhaupt auch
sozial wieder aktiv zu werden um auch da
unterstützung zu erfahren und das ist
all das was jetzt letztlich wegfällt und
deswegen ist umso wichtiger
dass genau diese menschen versuchen sich
hilfe zu suchen entweder tatsächlich bei
einem psychotherapeuten wenn sie schon
erfahrungen mit dieser erkrankung haben
oder auch wenn es symptome sind die
einem wo man nicht selber genau weiß in
welche richtung geht es denn bei eben
angeboten die etwas niederschwelliger
sind telefonseelsorge zum beispiel
bücher zu lesen oder auch online
versuchen mit trainings sich da
irgendwie hilfe hilfe und impulse zu
suchen
darf ich da direkt mal einen haken denn
ich sehe dass in den verschiedenen jets
die leute ein bisschen frustriert sind
weil sie nicht genau wissen was sie
machen sollen wo sie hilfe suchen sollen
welche bücher sie lesen sollten welche
apps die laden solchen welche podcast zu
hören können können sie da vielleicht
ein paar empfehlen und wir versprechen
wenn sie welche empfehlen dann blenden
wir das auch ein oder liefern das
natürlich in den sozialen netzwerken
direkt damit man sich das dann auch
angucken kann also ich denke im bereich
der telefonseelsorge es gibt die
allgemeine telefonseelsorge
da findet man die nummer auch unter www
telefonseelsorge de und es gibt speziell
auch für schwierigkeiten die im rahmen
mit corona auftreten gibt es von der
katholischen kirche in der
telefonseelsorge die man unter corona -
seelsorge de findet auch die kontakte
und da gibt es auch entsprechend
unterschiedliche ansprechpartner für
erwachsene für kinder
das heißt zum beispiel auch kinder und
jugendliche sich da direkt hinwenden
können und ich glaube das ist eine sehr
gute möglichkeit wenn man akut einfach
wirklich bedarf hat über seine
schwierige situation und auch vielleicht
gerade einfach nur in schwierigen moment
an diesem tag wirklich mit jemandem zu
sprechen und mit jemandem zu sprechen
der da auch entsprechende erfahrung hat
und einem vielleicht einfach einen guten
hinweis geben kann
in bezug auf bücher ist vor allen dingen
eben in bezug auf die residenz die
widerstandskraft die psychische
widerstandskraft würde ich so zwei oder
drei bücher empfehlen eines wenn man
vielleicht auch ein bisschen mehr an den
hintergründen interessiert ist hat mein
kollege aus mainz raphael kalisch ein
buch geschrieben das heißt die residente
mensch und da geht er aber auch sehr
stark auf die ganzen unterschiedlichen
forschungsergebnisse ein aber ich glaube
für den ein oder anderen
auch das ganz spannend sein um sich dem
thema zu nähern und da interessante
anregung zu finden und frau christina
berndt das ist eigentlich schon
klassiker war auch ein spiegel
bestseller hat ein ganz tolles buch
geschrieben das heißt einfach resilienz
und ein zweites zufriedenheit wo man
ganz viele anregungen finde ich schon
findet wie man trotz schwieriger phasen
vielleicht eben zufriedenheit findet wie
man psychisch widerstandsfähig sein kann
und auch ganz viele fallbeispiele
nachlesen kann und es gibt manchmal auch
ein gewissen halt wenn man eben über
andere menschen liest wie die situation
tatsächlich bewältigt haben
die universität lüneburg die bietet
relativ viele online trainings an und
auch online trainings zum beispiel für
depressive patienten und es könnte jetzt
in der aktuellen situation natürlich
eine gute ergänzung sein
und das findet man unter get on
training.de und der kollege leer ist
jemand der auf diesem gebiet einfach
wahnsinnig erfahren ist und die haben
eine ganze reihe von trainings und apps
entwickelt auch eine app zur dankbarkeit
die wirklich eine ganz gute wirksamkeit
zeigen und mit denen man glaube ich auch
einfach gute impulse sich selber noch
mal geben kann wo man vielleicht noch
gar nicht so sehr darüber nachgedacht
hat und letztlich gibt es ganz schön
podcast von einer kollegin der
psychologin und eine radio moderatorin
der diane hielscher vom deutschlandfunk
der heißt achtsam und er spricht sie
eben über achtsamkeit auch mit der
psychologin und ich glaube das ist auch
immer etwas wo man schöne anregungen
bekommt und es ist eigentlich ganz egal
ob man sich jetzt im moment wahnsinnig
belastet fühlt oder gar nicht so sehr
man kann damit gar nicht viel falsch
machen und hat einfach wirklich so einen
bunten strauß wo man für sicher gucken
kein mensch vielleicht probiere ich das
einfach und es hilft mir über manche
schwierige zeiten hinweg das waren sehr
viele konkrete tipps frau professor
wässer vielen dank dafür und ich würde
gemeinsam zum abschluss des gesprächs
gerne mit ihnen noch mal einen punkt
aufgreifen und mit ihnen ich weiß nicht
ob sie es sehen können aber die
userinnen und user kann sehen das bild
aus berlin zeigen wo wir sehen dass die
kollegen auf die pressekonferenz warten
und wir sehen viele leere stühle und wir
sehen davor im bild nur zu erkennen vier
kollegen die sitzen alle mit abstand die
sitzen da jetzt schon weil sie eben
warten müssen bis es losgeht und sie
tragen alle eine maske das kann man
jetzt zumindest von hinten nicht
wirklich sehen aber ich gehe davon aus
dass es so ist und wir haben uns in
dieser pandemie daran gewöhnt dass das
völlig normal ist vorher war es
allerdings so dass diese kollegen noch
gar nicht in diesem saal drin gewesen
wären die hätten sich unterhalten die
hätten noch einen kaffee zusammen
getrunken vorne im foyer und jetzt ist
das eben die situation in dieser
pandemie in der wir darauf warten dass
es ein nächstes ergebnis einer erneuten
bund länder konferenz gibt aber wir
halten dieses bild frau professor wetter
eben inzwischen schon für völlig normal
und dazu schreibt über youtube der user
darfst templin
ich habe angst dass der mensch von
seinen mitmenschen in zukunft nur noch
als potenzielle gefahr wahrgenommen wird
und sich das mit den abständen auch nach
der pandemie in den köpfen festsetzt
könnte das passieren
also ganz ehrlich muss ich sagen dass
ich dafür fast am wenigsten angst habe
und es gibt zwei gründe dafür ich glaube
der eine grund ist die erfahrung dass
wir auch im letzten jahr gesehen haben
dass wir recht schnell eigentlich viel
schneller als das glaube ich viele
gedacht haben auch zu einer normalität
zurückfinden und eigentlich er sehr
erleichtert sind und auch wieder
genießen ein stück weit normal mit
anderen umgehen zu können ich glaube
schon dass bleibt dass man mit manchen
situationen vielleicht vorsichtiger
umgeht und ich finde auch eigentlich
dass das vielleicht auch etwas positives
sein kann dass bestimmte dinge
vielleicht auch gar nicht sein müssen
und dass wir uns auch viele freiheiten
nehmen die möglicherweise auch gar nicht
unbedingt sozusagen uns und allen
anderen dienlich sind aber ich glaube
wir werden da schnell wieder
zurückfinden und zwar weil es auch ein
ganz primäres bedürfnis für uns ist es
ist ein sehr starkes bedürfnis und auch
evolutionär bedingt dass wir anderen
nahe sind und dass wir uns mit anderen
sozusagen umgeben und ich glaube dass
sobald das möglich ist wir die vorsicht
auch irgendwann überwinden die
übertriebene vorsicht und dass wir das
auch wieder genießen werden
da bin ich ganz zuversichtlich und
optimistisch ein guter ausblick vielen
herzlichen dank dank frau professor
besser in die pfalz führt das gespräch
und danke dass sie mit uns gewartet
haben einen schönen abend ihnen noch und
damit mögliche er gerne das wünsche ich
ihnen auch danke schön danke damit
möchte ich gerne wieder da sehen wir
ihnen wieder den saal an dem sich nichts
verändert hat zu meiner kollegin nicole
diekmann nach berlin gehen und zwar
direkt mit der frage über youtube von
vlotho gs welche sachen werden
wahrscheinlich als erstes geöffnet
welche sachen er zum schluss
sehr wahrscheinlich werden als erste
schulen und kindergärten geöffnet und
friseursalons das ist jetzt schon klar
sofern man jetzt schon von klarheit
reden kann bevor diese stühle auf die
ich hier auch auf dem fernseher neben
mir gucke besetzt sind mit denjenigen
die heute entscheidung getroffen haben
und jetzt verkünden dürfen also
friseursalons entweder 22 februar oder
märz das sind jetzt so die daten die
hier kursieren
und dann gibt es in der beschlussvorlage
fassung die wir im moment hier haben
da werden geschäfte schon erwähnt museen
galerien die sollen aber am dritten märz
da soll das nächste treffen seien dann
auch noch mal sehr genau unter die lupe
genommen werden gemeinsam mit der bis
dahin dann existierende inzidenz liegt
die bei 50 könnte man dann eventuell
über erste öffnung natürlich immer noch
mit hygiene konzepten die dahinter
stehen müssen und auflagen wie zum
beispiel pro kunde pro kundin 20
quadratmeter also umgekehrt dürfen pro
quadratmeter dann eben nur eine person
rein in so ein laden darüber will man
dann reden das bleibt aber alles noch
einen ungefähren was sicherlich auch
damit zu tun hat dass es noch keine
daten darüber gibt und
anscheinend auch die mutter die
mutationen noch nicht so zugeschlagen
durchgeschlagen hier jetzt habe ich den
faden verlor ich das nochmal
man trifft sich ja heute auch und
diskutiert ohne zahlenmaterial ohne
wally das zahlenmaterial was die
mutationen betrifft da steht aber über
einen und das wird sicherlich dann auch
am dritten märz wenn man sich das
nächste mal treffen will dann auch noch
mal eine rolle spielen eventuell schlägt
sich das dann eben auch schon in zahlen
nieder was sicherlich relativ spät
geöffnet werden wird sind sagen wir mal
so orte wie fitnessstudios oder klubs ja
also discobus wie man das in meiner
generation noch gesagt hat da ist man
sicherlich noch vorsichtig weil es da
einfach schwierig ist auch zu
kontrollieren das war ja auch immer das
argument restaurants cafés zu schließen
ja also da kann man zwar die leute auch
auseinandersetzen vereins das ist ja ein
wort das wir den letzten monaten auch
immer wieder verwendet haben aber unter
alkoholeinfluss ist es daneben auch
schwierig so die argumentation der
politik da dann tatsächlich nicht
irgendwann die hemmungen fallen zu
lassen und ein bisschen enger
zusammenzurücken
das heißt also wenn ich hier die 2
kommentare aufgreifen über facebook
steffi schwalbach schreibt ich finde es
nicht richtig nur friseure und schulen
zu öffnen was ist mit der kultur
freizeit sport restaurants etc
das ist viel viel wichtiger für uns
menschen und stärkt die gemeinschaft und
überall liegt doch an hygiene konzept
vor
öffnet fitnessstudios tanzschulen und
die musikschule und auch über youtube
schreibt ist griff
wann dürfen hotels öffnen wer weiß
bescheid
das sieht also so aus als ist das lange
lange lange nicht in sicht und wenn man
dann vielleicht gerade hofft dass es
jetzt in sich ist dann kommen die neuen
zahlen zur mutation und machen alles
wieder zunichte
das kann so kommen und zum stichwort
hotels also was klar in diesem papier
steht ist man solle
wir alle sollten vorerst weiterhin davon
absehen touristische reisen zu
unternehmen auch zu verwandten
also wenn man diese touristischen reisen
nicht unternimmt muss man auch nicht ins
hotel
das ist also im moment überhaupt noch
nicht in sichtweite dass man überhaupt
nur über die lockerung was hotels angeht
was urlauber angeht spricht
das betrifft natürlich die branche hart
hier kommt jetzt eine frage zu den
hilfen
von simone mathea wann werden endlich
die november hilfen für gastronomen
ausgezahlt und die dezember hilfen das
ist ja auch ein riesen punkt dass sich
da viele beschwerden und sagen das läuft
einfach hinten und vorne nicht genau
also das ist ein riesen punkt die frage
kann natürlich auch nicht beantworten es
gibt dann diejenigen in der politik die
sagen naja läuft ja das ist natürlich so
funktioniert auch politik so
funktioniert politische kommunikation
zumal wir eine super wahl haben und alle
auch super gewählt werden wollen aber
das taucht hier nochmal in diesem papier
auf das wird noch einmal aufgegriffen
das thema aber es ist wie es ist und
sorgt für großen streit es gab ja in den
vergangenen tagen viel kritik an
bundeswirtschaftsminister altmaier dem
vorgeworfen wird er habe da nicht
vernünftig gearbeitet und das hören wir
war auch wohl noch mal thema in der
jetzt noch laufenden sitzung
apropos thema in der jetzt noch
laufenden sitzung welche rolle spielen
denn die impfungen wenn ich auf seite 2
dieses papiers lese dann ist da von
einer großartigen leistung der
wissenschaft die rede und die zügige
impfung der bevölkerung ist die
voraussetzung kleine summary liebe
nicole was kann man dann zum thema
impfen erzählen zum thema impfen kann
man erzählen das jetzt zum beispiel
eu-kommissionspräsident in ursula von
der leyen doch tatsächlich auch einzelne
fehler bei der bestellung eingeräumt hat
man habe also man sei zu zögerlich
gewesen man habe zu spät erkannt wie die
produktion von statten geht in welchem
tempo also super
wie das teilweise noch dargestellt wird
ist es natürlich nicht was aber auch
also und das ist natürlich insofern
problematisch als die impfung ja als der
lichtblick gilt ja die impfung ist das
worauf jetzt alle schauen wenn diese
also auch das steht noch mal im papier
bis ende des sommers sollen wir alle
einem versprechen bekommen haben
isla von allein spricht von 70 prozent
der eu-bevölkerung die dann geimpft sein
sollen
wenn ein so elementarer baustein so
problematisch anläuft und für so viel
offenen soft sorgt auch zwischen bund
und ländern die länder sagen ja zum teil
wir haben hier aus dem nichts quasi
impfzentren aus dem boden gestampft und
dann schicken wir leute wieder nach
hause dann schicken wir weinen die leute
wieder nach hause weil wir zwar den
platz hätten um sie zu impfen
aber nicht den impfstoff weil wir nicht
genug davon bekommen und wir bekommen
keine verlässlichen aussagen wann denn
was in welcher menge eintrifft so dass
wir dann besser planen können und mehr
verlässlichkeit bieten
also das ist natürlich dann schwierig
wenn das vertrauen dadurch so schwindet
und dann ich habe es ja heute schon mal
gesagt dass die impfmüdigkeit dadurch
bei den leuten wächst also man sich da
vielleicht nicht mehr so bereit erklärt
sich impfen zu lassen wie man das
vielleicht getan hätte wenn man sie gar
das geht jetzt mit schwung voran
das ist ein großes problem und ich
möchte noch eines sagen wieder taucht in
diesem papier etwas nicht auf mit keiner
silbe und das ist die korona app und
erinnern wir uns mal was im vergangenen
sommer mit was für einem medialen tamtam
diese app begleitet wurde die spielt
überhaupt keine rolle mehr auch das
trägt natürlich dazu bei dass das die
kritik groß ist und dass das misstrauen
auch gegenüber der impfung zum beispiel
wächst also nicht der impfung selber
sondern der zuverlässigkeit was im
versprechen angeht dass das wächst
nicole ich fürchte dass viele
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer die in den
letzten minuten oder sekunden nicht mehr
richtig folgen konnten weil sie so
abgelegt davon waren was hinter dir
passiert und offenbar es das passiert
was einfache kurzem angekündigt hat er
hat sich abgeschaltet jetzt ist schwarz
hinter dir
ich würde dir kurz gelegenheit geben das
hinter dir wieder schick zu machen wenn
du möchtest und mal gucken was hier
gerade für kommentare noch so
eingelaufen sind martha the great
schreibt wieso wird immer nur vom
einzelhandel kinder und kleinkindern
gesprochen was ist mit den studenten
darüber haben wir vorhin schon
gesprochen und nicole hat gesagt in
diesem paper steht nichts drin über
studenten also nach der beschlussvorlage
die uns bislang bekannt ist kann man
nicht davon ausgehen dass es für
studentinnen neue regelungen oder
möglichkeiten gibt über facebook
schreibt matthias wenn man friseur
eröffnet kann man auch die gastronomie
wieder öffnet für mich stellt beides
kein risiko dar
das haut so ein bisschen in die kerbe
auch vieler verbände die sagen wir waren
nicht die treiber der pandemie wir haben
gute hygiene konzepte von uns aus können
wir sehr gerne weitermachen wir sind
vorsichtig aber trotzdem sind sie
enttäuscht weil sie eben nicht wieder
aufmachen können weil der
gesundheitsminister auf der anderen
seite sagt man weiß gar nicht mehr woher
die betreiber der pandemie sofern man
das so überhaupt sagen kann kommen und
man kann gar nicht mehr zurückverfolgen
wo die neue infektionen entstehen
ich würde einen punkt versuchen mit
nicole noch einmal aufzugreifen denn der
spiegel zum beispiel macht gerade damit
auch vielleicht kann man auf meinem
notebook gerade nochmal switchen und
zeigen spiegel online schreibt hier auf
der startseite bund und länder wollen
früheres impfen von lehrern und
erziehern prüfen und nicole falls du
schon wieder zu hören kannst ist das in
der tat ein interessanter punkt weil wir
gerade miteinander über das impfen
gesprochen haben
denn wenn man das so liest und hört dann
ist es so dass angela merkel selbst
diesen impuls gegeben hat und
vorgeschlagen hat in dieser runde
lehrerinnen und lehrer und erzieherinnen
und erzieher
denn zu priorisieren damit man eben den
schulen und den kitas eine frühere
öffnung perspektive geben kann
nicole es immer noch schwarz ist egal
hauptsache du siehst gut aus und das
tust du und hauptsache
du kannst uns hören und sehen und die
fragen der userinnen und user
beantworten
nicole was ist denn mit der idee
lehrerinnen und lehrer zu priorisieren
ja die hat natürlich einen großen
schaden also das kommt ja eigentlich
auch dem sehr nahe was man in den alten
und pflegeheim getan hat bisher dass man
da auch versucht hat so viele wie
möglich der mitarbeiter innen dort zu
impfen
sicherlich ist das ein gau ring debatte
und lassen so zu formulieren
auch in den kindergärten soll das ja
passieren aber wie sie sehen sehen sie
nichts im moment sitzt da noch niemand
da müssen wir noch abwarten ob sich die
kanzlerin unter anderem mit ihrem werben
dafür durchgesetzt hat aber auch da gilt
natürlich dafür muss der impfstoff
vorhanden sein und das darf man sich
dann natürlich auch dass das gehört auch
zur wahrheit dann fährt er an einer
anderen stelle also dass ist so mit dem
priorisieren
wenn die einen etwas kriegen kriegen ist
die anderen nicht dafür müsste man dann
noch mal den impfplan umschmeißen
aber das ist ja sowieso immer mal wieder
im gange das musste ja auch passieren
als jetzt die ständige impfkommission
die stiko für den astra zeneca impfstoff
empfohlen hat ihn nur 18 bis 64 jährigen
zu impfen weil das er auch noch mal
angemerkt bei für ältere einfach noch
nicht genügend daten vorliegen es war ja
mal gemeldet worden
er würde nicht wirken das stimmt ja so
nicht das war eine falschmeldung sondern
ist zwar schlicht und einfach in der
studie nicht genügend mitglieder dieser
altersklasse vertreten
auch da muss man dann jetzt ja nochmal
umschwenken
also von daher können wir gespannt
bleiben die höheren jetzt ist könnte so
19 19 15 werden was da gleich bei der
pressekonferenz vielleicht auch zu
diesem thema gesagt wird ja dann würde
ich an dieser stelle gerne sozusagen den
sack zumachen und dann wieder mit dir
weitermachen wenn sich denn in berlin
konkret was tut eine letzte frage möchte
ich aber jetzt noch unterbringen apophis
die frau schreibt über youtube ist es
jetzt schon sicher dass der look down
verlängert wird fragezeichen
ich glaube davon können wir sehr sehr
stark ausgehen es geht nicht um die
frage ob sondern um die frage wie lange
dann an dieser stelle vielen dank nicole
und wir sehen uns gleich wieder und sie
zu hause verpassen natürlich überhaupt
nichts denn wenn es losgeht dann werden
wir für sie da sein
das gleiche ist
[Musik]
ja
nein
im fall war
ja
die zusagen werden
[Musik]
ja liebe userinnen und user liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer hier ist
zdf heute live mit einer nächsten
ausgabe einer pressekonferenz von angela
merkel und den vorsitzenden der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz zu den
neuen corona beschlüssen live aus berlin
sie jetzt über die ergebnisse der
beratungen
ja meine damen und herren wir haben uns
verabredet genießt heute wieder zu einer
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mit der
bundesregierung getroffen und haben
beraten
wie sieht die lage heute aus wenn ich
das noch mal kurz rekapitulieren kann
dann können wir sagen wir haben heute
eine instanz von 68 infektionen vor
hunderttausend einwohner in sieben tagen
als wir das letzte mal abgesehen vom
impfgipfel das letzte mal eine solche
konferenz hatten war das am 25 januar
und dort war die instanz 111 das heißt
wir haben eine deutliche differenz von
43 43 in etwa 16 tagen und das zeigt
dass die 50 incidents die er für uns
schon eine gewisse bedeutung hat
durchaus in reicht oder sichtweite ist
damals gab es vier landkreise die unter
50 incidents hatten heute sind es
alleine 45 landkreise unter 35 und
deutlich über 100 landkreise unter 50
wir haben zwar ein verlangsamtes tempo
der es runter gehens aber wir gehen
beständig unter bisher die zahl der
intensivbetten die belegt ist ist immer
noch 800 mehr als im maximum des
frühjahrs aber immer
2000 weniger als ende dezember anfang
januar
und wenn wir uns diese entwicklung
angucken könnte man sehr zufrieden sein
jetzt können auch sehr zufrieden sein
ich möchte den bürgerinnen und bürgern
danken die das durch ihr verhalten
gerade auch im privaten bereich aber du
auch durch viele home office durch
weniger reisen ermöglicht haben
denen gebührt unser dank und es zeigt
sich dass die verhängten maßnahmen die
ja oft sehr strikt auf sehr hart auf
sehr mühselig sind doch ihre wirkung
zeigen
heute wollten wir nun diskutieren wie es
weitergeht und wir müssen leider die es
im lichte einer entwicklung tun die wir
alle im vergangenen jahr noch nicht
voraussehen konnten nämlich in der
entwicklung einer oder verschiedener
mutationen des virus wir haben den
ersten bericht über diese veränderten
viren bekommen durch sequenzierung die
in deutschland in ende ja im ende januar
durchgeführt wurden
damals ist ein prozentsatz von 57
prozent der britischen variante im
wesentlichen und weniger fälle der
südafrikanischen variante uns
vorgestellt worden
wir
wissen dass diese mutationen also jetzt
eine realität ist und damit wird sie zu
nehmen
die frage ist wie schnell nimmt sie zu
und wir wissen dass unser erfolg nicht
unter 0,7 licht er liegt meistens bei
0,8 willkommen 85 wenn diese variante um
0,3 aggressiver ist dann würde unser
reproduktions fährt wieder bei über 1
liegen das heißt wir würden sehr schnell
im exponentiellen wachstum sein
deshalb ist da eine dritte welle
angelegt die wir bekämpfen müssen und
die können wir nur bekämpfen wenn man
den incident zahlen wirklich runter
kommen wenn die gesundheitsämter wieder
die kontrolle über das virus bekommen in
dem sinne dass sie die kontakte
nachverfolgen können dann können wir
auch bei lockerungsschritte die inzidenz
weiter senken und das ist ja das was wir
wollen und deshalb ist die zeitspanne
zwischen jetzt und mitte märz die
experten sagen dass die mutierten viren
die oberhand gewinnen könnten über das
bisherige virus diese zeitspanne ist so
existenziell dass wir da weiter unsere
instanzen senken und deshalb müssen wir
auch sehr vorsichtig sein neben der
kontakt nach verfolgung für die
gesundheitsämter spielen hier übrigens
auch die erweiterten testmöglichkeiten
eine rolle denn wir haben natürlich ganz
anders als im frühjahr inzwischen durch
die schnelltests und vielleicht bald
auch durch die selbsttests möglichkeiten
der überwachung die wir sonst nicht
hatten
wir wollen alles tun damit wir nicht in
eine wellenbewegung hoch und runter auf
und zu kommen sondern indem wir
vorsichtig unsere öffnungen und
lockerungen machen immer unter der
maßgabe dass wir beobachten müssen
welcher schritt hat welche auswirkung
und was bedeutet das dann für die
entwicklung der fallzahlen
wir haben immer wieder haben
noch einmal deutlich gemacht dass
bestimmte maßnahmen erhalten bleiben die
kontakte beschränkungen nicht notwendige
private und reisen und besucher sollen
unterlassen werden und die aufforderung
zum home office die ja auch bis zum 15
märz gilt vorerst die soll sehr ernst
genommen werden
wir wissen dass bildung priorität hat
das haben wir alle immer wieder gesagt
und deshalb sind die bereiche von kita
und schule von äußerster bedeutung
ich habe bestimmte eigene vorstellungen
gehabt über das öffnen von
kindertagesstätten tagesstätten und auch
schulen die er auf eine öffnung um den
ersten märz also zum ersten märz ging
weil ich glaube dass wir dieses datum
sehr voraussehbar anpeilen können für
eine instanz von 50 aber ich weiß auch
dass wir in einem föderalen staat leben
und der föderalismus ist unter dem
strich die beste für die bessere ordnung
als ein zentralismus davon bin ich
zutiefst überzeugt selbst wenn es
manchmal etwas mühsam ist und es gibt
ganz ganz eindeutige und tief stehen
tief verankerte blender zuständigkeiten
das sind schule und kita
und da ist es ganz einfach nicht möglich
dass ich als bundeskanzlerin mich so
durchsetzen kann als hätte ich da ein
veto recht wie das zum beispiel in der
europäischen union bei einstimmigkeit
möglich ist und deshalb haben wir gesagt
die kulturhoheit zählt hier und die
länder werden das in eigener
verantwortung und sicherlich dann auch
noch dargestellt durch die
ländervertreter entscheiden wir liegen
da gar nicht so weit auseinander für
mich ist nur diese instanz von 50 als
ein leitfaden sehr wichtig und da wir
sonst ein großes hohes maß an einigkeit
haben haben wir diese beschlüsse jetzt
auch so gemeinsam
gefasst wie sie hier wieder gelegt sind
wir haben uns entschieden dass friseure
zum ersten märz öffnen werden eben
gerade weil zu diesem tag dann auch mit
großer wahrscheinlichkeit eine 50er
inzidenz deutschlandweit zu erreichen
ist wir haben darüber gesprochen wie
sehen denn nächste eröffnungs schritte
aus und bei diesen nächsten eröffnungs
schritten ist ja sehr wichtig dass wir
perspektiven aufzeigen auf der einen
seite aber auf der anderen seite
natürlich auch immer damit leben müssen
dass wir die zukunft nicht voraussagen
können und deshalb haben wir gesagt aus
heutiger perspektive insbesondere vor
dem hintergrund der unsicherheit
bezüglich der verbreitung von virus
mutanten kann der nächste öffnungs
schritt bei einer stabilen sieben tage
instanz von höchstens 35 neuinfektionen
pro 100000 einwohner rund 100 durch die
länder erfolgen
dieser nächste öffnungs schritt soll die
öffnung des einzelhandels mit einer
begrenzung von einer kundin oder im
kunden pro 20 quadratmeter umfassen
dazu die öffnung von museen und galerien
sowie die öffnung der noch geschlossenen
körpernahen dienstleistungsbetriebe es
müssen dann natürlich wenn das länder
weit gemacht wird mit den nachbarländern
auch entsprechende vorkehrungen
getroffen werden dass es nicht zu einem
einkaufstourismus kommt wir werden dann
für die weiteren bereiche die wir hier
auch nennen nämlich kontakt
beschränkungen im persönlichen bereich
kultur sport in gruppen freizeit
gastronomie und hotelgewerbe schritt für
schritt weitere öffnung schritte
vereinbart
aber dieser erste größere schritt nach
schule und friseurin ist dann einer den
wir bei einer konstanten stabilen
instanz von höchstens 35 neue
infektionen gehen und
ich glaube das ist etwas woran auch
jeder orientieren kann manche sagen das
ist ja ein so niedriger wert kann man
den erreichen und da will ich nochmal
auf meine eingangs bemerkung hinweis und
wir haben in den vergangenen tagen der
25 januar ist nicht ewig her 43 punkte
incidents sind darunter gegangen von 50
auf 35 sind es 15 punkte das heißt beim
weiteren sinkenden verlauf das heißt
natürlich müssen alle anderen
restriktionen auch einheiten kann man
das durchaus erreichen und das ist in
einer reichweite wir haben dann über das
impfen gesprochen über die weitere
unterstützung der altenpflegeheime und
andere punkte die durch jetzt nicht
einzelne ausführen die sind in unseren
beschluss dargestellt ich will nur noch
einmal darauf hinweisen dass heute der
bundeswirtschaftsminister
eine ankündigung machen konnte die
sehnlichst und dringend erwartet wurde
nämlich zu den überbrückungshilfen 3
seit heute mittag oder nachmittag können
diese online beantragt werden
damit wurde auch der zeitplan der immer
in aussicht gestellt wurde eingehalten
die antragsteller werden innerhalb
weniger tage er legt sich fest
spätestens bis zum 15
februar in einem automatisierten
verfahren großzügige abschlagszahlungen
in höhe von bis zu 400.000 euro erhalten
100.000 pro monat und die endgültigen
bescheide erfolgen dann durch die länder
ab dem monat märz ich glaube das ist für
viele die echte große
liquiditätsprobleme haben und natürlich
auch sonderopfer bringen jetzt im
zusammenhang mit der chorakademie eine
wichtige und sehnlich erwartete
mitteilung die wir heute machen konnten
das von meiner seite zu unseren heutigen
beschlüssen wir werden uns am dritten
märz wieder treffen und dann weitere
fragen natürlich besprechen und vor
allem die situation analysieren
angesichts der des zunehmenden anteils
der mutation wird man dann die lage
wieder bewerten muss
deshalb finde ich das datum dritter märz
sehr gut das heißt die von uns heute
gefassten beschlüsse gilt gelten erst
mal bis zum 7
vielen dank ich will gleich zu anfang
betonen wie sehr ich mich darüber freue
dass der weg den wir vor einigen wochen
miteinander verabredet haben so gut und
so erfolgreich ist dass wir jetzt sehen
wie die zahlen bundesweit nach unten
gehen und wie wichtig es auch war diesen
weg zu verabreden denn all das was wir
jetzt erreichen konnten in den letzten
tagen insbesondere wo die zahlen noch
einmal bundesweit sehr deutlich nach
unten gegangen sind bisher nicht von
alleine gekommen
und das muss man wirklich immer wieder
sagen und ich weiß wie es auch zu
einzelnen punkten kritik gibt und wie
man sich natürlich insgesamt wünscht
dass alles noch viel schneller geht und
wir alle auch ein stückweit coroner müde
sind und manche themen auch nicht mehr
hören können
aber wir sehen dass es nicht vergeblich
war an dem berliner beispiel sieht man
es wir waren anfang dezember fast trotz
dort wir waren fast bei einer 200er
inzidenz und sind heute nach lkw zahlen
das bundesland mit den niedrigsten
instanzen ist nicht von alleine gekommen
noch einmal
es sind die beschlüsse die an den
richtigen stellen nachjustiert haben es
war ein besonderer politischer weg der
gegangen wurde und und deswegen an
dieser stelle auch ein großes dankeschön
einen weg der von unglaublich vielen
menschen solidarisch mitgetragen wurde
sonst hätten wir das nicht erreicht
weder in berlin noch in einem anderen
bundesland
und dieser weg wiederum so mühsam und so
ermüdend er auch ist hat vielen menschen
das leben gerettet
auch das darf man nicht vergessen wir
haben tausende die wegen dieses weges
und dieses erfolges nicht in ein
krankenhaus mussten und nicht auf eine
intensivstation
und auch da sehen wir inzwischen die
entlastung wie ich finde immer noch zu
gering aber auch da wieder heute das
erste mal seit wochen in berlin in
unserer corona ampel ein gelbes signal
für die auslastung der intensivbetten
wochen lang stand dieses signal auf rot
und auch das macht ein
erfreuliche tendenz deutlich und gerade
vor diesem hintergrund über den ich mich
sehr freue
finde ich so wichtig was wir heute
wieder miteinander verabredet haben
nämlich zum einen dass wir diesen weg
jetzt auch nicht aufgeben ich glaube es
wäre fatal jetzt ein zwei wochen zu früh
zu sagen nun haben wir es doch erreicht
jetzt sind wir doch durch und dann waren
es vielleicht genau die ein zwei wochen
die uns zum schluss fehlen um ganz
deutlich noch mal runter zu kommen noch
viel deutlich herunter zu kommen mit den
instanzen noch viel mehr entlastung zu
haben auf den intensivstationen noch
mehr möglichkeiten zu haben wieder im
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst instanzen
auch nachzuverfolgen ausbruchsherde
nachzuverfolgen und damit ja dann auch
zu zu unterbinden
jetzt kommt wirklich gerade nach diesem
schweren wochen finde ich darauf an
genau diese wochen jetzt auch noch
durchzuhalten damit wir dann wirklich
sagen können wir haben so viel erreicht
dass man wieder guten gewissens ganz
andere schritte hin zu einer normalität
auch wieder sich vornehmen kann
wir haben also glaube ich auch heute
wieder das sehr besonnen miteinander
formuliert diesen weg im grundsatz
weiter zu gehen und tatsächlich ein
punkt heraus zugreifen der uns allen
genau so am herzen liegt mir das ganze
thema gesundheitsschutz das ist nämlich
die situation der kinder und
jugendlichen und wie geht es an den
schulen weiter eine ganz schwierige
abwägungsfrage ganz ganz schwierig da
auch ein das gut auszubalancieren was
man sich vornehmen kann und wie weit man
geht aber wir sehen auf der einen seite
was beim thema gesundheitsschutz weiter
passieren muss und wir sehen auf der
anderen seite wie soziale folgen auch
sind wenn schulen und kindertagesstätten
einrichtung über monate geschlossen sind
und insofern war das allen ländern sehr
sehr wichtig auch ja auch da wieder ein
stück perspektive zu bieten für die
kinder natürlich auch für die eltern und
nicht zuletzt auch für die lehrerinnen
und lehrer auch wieder ein stück
normalität und planungssicherheit zu
geben
es ist sehr wie ich finde sehr sehr gut
auch wieder formuliert worden dass wir
natürlich im moment über die
grundschulen reden wir reden wenn wir
sagen wir wollen
senz betrieb in den an den schulen
ermöglichen reden wir nicht über das was
wir kennen von anfang 2020 bevor wir uns
mit der pandemie auseinandersetzen
mussten sondern wir reden hier über ein
schrittweises hochfahren des präsents
betriebes beginnend an den grundschulen
und dann auch wieder mit wechseln
unterricht mit abstand und hygieneregeln
mit luftfiltern und vor allen dingen
auch mit nochmals verstärkten
testeinsatz für die lehrerinnen und
lehrer und so weit dass jetzt auch
möglich ist mit neuen testverfahren
neuen testmöglichkeiten und kapazitäten
natürlich auch für die kinder wenn wir
da jetzt in den nächsten wochen eine
entlastung bekommen dass die selbsttests
in anderem umfang auch einzusetzen sind
auch viel schonender einzusetzen sind
dass es nicht mehr diese unangenehmen
abstriche gibt bis tief in der nase
sondern dass man auch anders aus dem
vorderen nasenbereich oder wachenbereich
den abstrich nehmen kann dann ist das
natürlich auch etwas womit man ja
wiederum viel mehr eltern und kinder
erreicht und daneben auch über diese
testmöglichkeiten noch mehr sicherheit
zu gewinnen wie ist eigentlich die
situation an den schulen wir sind die
infektionsgeschehen wo kann man und muss
man auch schnell reagieren
wir konnten glaub ich guten gewissens
auch diesen weg gehen weil wir
einerseits natürlich auch wissen durch
die beratung der wissenschaft schule
kann man nicht außen vor lassen bei
meinen infektionsgeschehen das muss man
mit betrachten natürlich gibt es auch
infektionsgeschehen an den schulen oder
ausgelöst von den schulen oder den
kindern aber nach wie vor sagen uns auch
alle wissenschaftler noch in der letzten
woche es gibt keine besonderen
auffälligkeiten bei den kindern und
schon gar nicht bei den ganz jungen und
genau in dieser abwägung was müssen wir
weiter tun um unseren erfolgreichen weg
weiter zu gehen und was müssen wir tun
um eben auch da jetzt aus sozialen
gründen ja auch nicht nur aus
bildungspolitischen ein gutes angebot zu
machen an den schulen aus diesen
abwägungs gründen sind jetzt eben zu dem
ergebnis gekommen dass schon im februar
dann auch die schulen wie im
beschriebenen schrittweise öffnen können
und ein präsenzunterricht anbieten kann
für berlin kann ich
wir werden das für den 22 februar
organisieren ich glaube sehr viele
länder orientieren sich auch an dem 22
ich will noch etwas sagen zu dem thema
friseure
das spielt hier eine große rolle staune
darüber manche debatte wie groß die
rolle ist die die friseure spielen aber
auch da wieder haben wir es uns nicht
leicht gemacht weder in die eine noch in
die andere richtung sondern es gab
einfach vielfache hinweise dass das
ähnlich zu betrachten es wie eine eine
psychologische versorgung das für viele
menschen die sich nicht selbst versorgen
können und einfach sagen ich lasse die
haare wachsen oder ich kümmere mich
selbst wird schon irgendwie gehen dass
viele menschen einfach da auch aus
hygienischen gründen unterstützung
brauchen ähnlich wie bei der fußpflege
und deswegen haben wir gesagt das ist
noch einmal ein besonderer bereich den
greifen wir darüber hinaus hinauf und
und wollen da ermöglichen dass ab dem
ersten märz wieder ein betrieb angeboten
werden kann natürlich immer betonen ist
immer wieder auch wieder mit regeln
maske abstand hier gehen
spielt alles nach wie vor eine rolle und
abschließend von mir
es ist sehr sehr wichtig aus sicht
vieler ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten dass wir jetzt doch
mal deutlicher formuliert haben wofür
wir auch die nächsten schritte gehen
wollen was das ziel ist diese 35
incidents die bundeskanzlerin
angesprochen hat ist ein wichtiges ziel
das zu erreichen es ist ein wichtiges
ziel in bezug auf den gesundheitsschutz
ist aber auch ein wichtiges ziel eben um
wieder normalität zurück zu gewinnen
und es soll eben ganz konkret bei so
einer inzidenz auch möglich sein wieder
den einzelhandel zu öffnen auch aus dem
kulturbereich die museen die galerien
auch nicht willkürlich herausgegriffen
die museen wir wissen dann kann da auch
sehr gut steuern über ein online ticket
verfahren über
ein anmeldeverfahren kann man sehr gut
steuern und beobachten und kontrollieren
wie viele menschen bewegen sich auf
welchem raum also aber auch wieder der
kultur ein stück perspektive zu
ermöglichen einen ersten schritt hin zu
einer normalität glaube dass das sehr
sehr wichtig ist und dass wir darüber
hinaus in einer arbeitsgruppe bund und
länder der cds und der
ministerpräsidenten uns dann wiederum
mit den noch weitergehenden schritten
beschäftigen zum nächsten mal ist auch
richtig
niedersachsen schleswig holstein sachsen
sachsen anhalt thüringen wir in berlin
viele andere haben ministerpräsidenten
haben doch auch überlegungen wie kann
denn so einen rahmenplan so ein
stufenplan aussehen für die nächsten
monate und im übrigen für beide
richtungen für lockern und ermöglichen
und auch einschränken und das jetzt auch
ausgehend von dem was wir jetzt heute
beschlossen haben von diesen konkreten
perspektiven und zielen davon ausgehend
dass weiterzuentwickeln und
aufzuschreiben sind glaube ich auch
wieder ganz wichtigen ist ja schritte
also insofern glaube ich dass das heute
auch wieder ein längerer tag als
eigentlich dachten aber doch ein sehr
erfolgreicher und wichtiger tag war auch
im rahmen der pandemie bekämpfung und
auch um ein stück perspektive bieten zu
können wofür diese anstrengung auch
tatsächlich nötig sind herr
ministerpräsident sie haben nicht sehr
verehrten damen und herren die mitbürger
und bürger sind wie ehrlich es ist
leichter zu machen als zu öffnen zu
machen erfordert mut öffnen erfordert
klugheit
insofern ist der prozess deutlich
schwieriger zu gestalten und mit mehr
dinge zu beachten
positiv ist sehr positiv ist dass alle
maßnahmen die wir getroffen haben dürfen
wir in bayern haben die zahlen der
infizierten um 90 prozent gesenkt um 90
prozent seit dem höhepunkt der massen
also das heißt jeder der zweifelt ob die
maßnahmen und sinn hatten
der ist durch die realität widerlegt das
stimmt also es wirkt das war nicht
umsonst all der einsatz hat sich absolut
gelohnt
das ist das eine das zweite es bleibt
aber noch ein weg weil es ist natürlich
so dass viele menschen gestresst sind
müde sind existenzen sind betroffen
das heißt es ist tatsächlich so dass die
lage besser aber die stimmung
schwieriger geworden ist so kann man
glaube ich die situation in unserem land
beschreiben die lage ist besser aber die
stimmung ist schwieriger
wie gehen wir jetzt damit um
insbesondere deswegen weil die einen
sich erleichterung wünschen die andere
aber in großer sorge sind wie geht es
jetzt weiter
die bundeskanzlerin hat zu recht die
situation der mutation angesprochen
das ist eine variable die wir derzeit
nicht abschließend dort sein können
wir wissen nur sie ist da wir wissen sie
wird stärker
sie spüren dass sie sich beginnt auch
durchzusetzen und dominant zu werden die
eine höhere ansteckung verhalten mit
sich bringen kann
und wir spüren von den grenzen ihren
bayern besonders wenn ich ab tschechien
denke oder österreich auch den druck so
dass ich glaube dass am ende das auch zu
mutations gebieten werden müssten weil
dort neben südafrika und andere
varianten hoch gefährlich unterwegs sind
also wie gehen wir jetzt in dieser
situation um das war unser ziel
unser ziel war vorsicht mit perspektive
sündige vorsicht mit perspektive wieder
dass eine nicht stur festhalten an einem
eimer beschlossenen konzept aber auch
nicht leichtfertig verstolpern
und man den rückfall zu riskieren ein
stop and go zu haben denn das wäre aus
unserer sicht der größte gefahren wenn
die akzeptanz die immer noch sehr hoch
ist der bevölkerung wird geschwächt wenn
man dann vor zurück an hin und her oder
stop and go macht und deswegen ist wenn
man das ganze beschrieben
vorsicht mit perspektive wurde
perspektive mit vorsichtige von welcher
fall wenn man sich dem thema annähern
möchte
wir haben das versprechen gehalten die
priorität bei den familien zu setzen
deswegen für die bereiche schule und
kita ist wenn die länder unterschiedlich
schnell machen mir eher etwas vorsichtig
und zurückhaltend im vergleich zu
anderen aber das entscheiden die länder
das macht auch deswegen übrigens noch
einen sinn weil wir gerade bei
grundschule
nur einen sehr regionalen einzugsbereich
haben und damit auch das regionale
infektionsgeschehen da einen gewissen
widerhall findet die entscheidung für
die friseure ist übrigens jetzt keine
einzelfall entscheidung sie hat auch
etwas mit für die ein hygiene aber ich
glaube auch mit würde zu tun in diesen
schwierigen zeiten ein bisschen auch mit
würde weil dies dann muss im internet
sind für so wichtig dass man sich dann
die stunde zu schnell
ich finde es schon und das spielt auch
eine rolle für viele menschen in dieser
pandemie sich selber auch wieder zu
finden und wir haben die perspektive mit
dieser zahl 35 entwickelt in seiner 35
ist neu
da wird sicher auch kritik daran gegeben
weil man sagt sich so wird eine neue
zahl jetzt etabliert das ist im grunde
genommen eine vorsichtige benchmark ob
der mutation eine vorsichtige benchmark
ob der mutation wobei man sagen muss
wenn die tendenz so weitergeht wie
bislang
wenn es so bliebe ist diese zahl im märz
nicht ausgeschlossen zu erreichen muss
man aus dem ich sagen das ist kein
vertagen auf den sankt nimmerleinstag im
gegenteil das kann er sein als man denkt
allerdings wenn es nicht die
entsprechend hohen sorgen mit mutation
wird deswegen glaube ich kann man sagen
ist es heute wieder eine sehr lange
diskussion gewesen aber eine fruchtbare
und es ist eine die glaube ich in diese
schwere zeit hinein passt mir ist völlig
klar wie sehr den menschen belastet sind
und ich bleibe dabei es ist eine große
leistung zur bevölkerung dass sie das
nicht nur alles mitmacht so dass viele
auch ganz engagiert dabei sind und das
sogar diejenigen denen existenz
herausgefordert sind akzeptieren dass
jetzt so zur maßnahme getroffen werden
die heutige garantieren das versprechen
des bundeswirtschaftsministers und
schließt übrigens der
bundesfinanzminister mit ein sie nicht
nur peter alten als auch herr scholz
beide sind ja für die wirtschaftshilfen
komplett verantwortlich
dieses versprechen und diese garantie
die bundeskanzlerin hat es jetzt einmal
präzisiert die ist extrem wichtig weil
sie spüren in der gastronomie dass dort
die zahlungen funktioniert haben das
heißt auch da ist das versprechen
absolut erfüllt worden dass auch die
unterstützung groß und auch die
bereitschaft diese schwierige zeit mit
zu gestalten
handel braucht jetzt ähnliche signale
also aus meiner sicht würde ich so sagen
perspektive mit vorsicht vorsicht mit
perspektive heißt langsamer als andere
länder es gemacht haben
vorsichtig als andere länder das gemacht
haben aber deswegen mit einem
sicherheitspuffer der uns so leicht die
chance bietet in der phase mit mehr
impfstoff den wir dann bekommen wollen
wir vor allem ab dem zweiten quartal
eine insgesamt verlässliche perspektive
zeigt aber dass das gelingt wird sich
zeigen
aber das scheint mir eine insgesamt
kluge ausgewogene und balancierte
strategie
wir sind bei ihren fragen nico fried von
der süddeutschen sie haben die erste
frau bundeskanzlerin die frage der
schulen war ja etwas was in den letzten
sitzungen immer wieder eine rolle
gespielt hat und auch immer wieder zu
konflikten zwischen ihnen und den
ministerpräsidenten geführt hat es gab
dann immer eine einheitliche regelung
von der einzelnen länder schon
abgewichen sind jetzt können die länder
tun und lassen was sie wollen fürchten
sie nicht dass es dadurch zu einer
situation kommt die völlig
unübersichtlich wird und auch
frustrationen schafft in der bevölkerung
da sind im einen land jetzt die kinder
schon wieder da und da zur schule gehen
können und im anderen land eben nicht
nein das möchte ich nicht weil das
verständnis der länder ja sehr
einheitlich ist das heißt auf der einen
seite kita öffnung das heißt auf der
anderen seite grundschule wechsel
unterricht und wir liegen ja jetzt auch
nicht meinen auseinander meine
vorstellung war der erste märz weil man
da die 50 incidents erreichen könnte
andere werden es an 22 machen es gibt
länder die werden auch sogar noch bis
zum 28 februar also erster märz warten
es wird vielleicht welche geben die auch
schon früher anfangen
ich glaube dass es eine überbrückbare
rahmen aber das ist kein völliges
auseinanderlaufen und ehrlich gesagt die
differenzen hat es auch vorher schon
gegeben
das verständnis unserer früheren
beschlüsse war ähnlich tipps parat und
ich habe mir einfach gesagt sie haben
viel gemeinsamkeit hier und ich finde
gerade heute haben wir viel
gemeinsamkeit
und dann muss ich einfach auch als
bundeskanzlerin akzeptieren dass unsere
föderale ordnung so ist dass die
kultusfreiheit einfach in den ländern
liegt das im übrigen auch die
verschiedenartigkeit innerhalb eines
landes da sein kann dass in einem
landkreis mit geringer instanz anders
behandelt wird als mit einem landkreis
mit hoher intelligenz
weil wir aber insgesamt uns über den
rahmen so sehr einig sind von friseuren
bis zum nächsten öffnungs schritt ist
das für mich das was sozusagen ja auch
die bestätigung einer gemeinsamen
philosophie unterstreicht und deshalb
bin ich da sehr dankbar ich will einen
punkt noch sagen wir jetzt noch nicht
erwähnt wurde den ich aber auch wichtig
finde das ist dass wir heute darüber
gesprochen haben wie gehen wir mit
erziehern und grundschullehrern um
bezüglich der impfung und da haben wir
festgestellt dass bund und länder den
bundesminister bundesminister der
gesundheit in absprache mit der
gesundheitsminister kontrollen zu bitten
zu prüfen ob bei der nächsten
fortschreibung der krone im vorort und
dieses thema wieder fortgeschrieben
beschäftigte in der kindertagesbetreuung
es um die grundschullehrerinnen und
-lehrer frühzeitiger als bisher
vorgesehen nämlich in der kategorie zwei
dieser in verordnung geimpft werden
können
wir glauben dass diese berufsgruppen
nicht die chance haben in ihrer
berufsausübung die notwendigen abstände
immer einzuhalten etwas was wir für
viele andere berufsgruppen ja
garantieren oder vom arbeitgeber fordern
und das deshalb wir dieses in der
infront verordnung tun sollten
das heißt nicht dass sozusagen sofort
eine impfung erfolgen kann
die gruppe 1 prioritäten gruppe eins
bleibt erhalten aber es ist ein signal
dass uns bildung und schule wirklich und
kita und schule so wichtig sind das was
aber auch bedeutet dass wir eine
besondere schutzpflicht für diese
beschäftigten haben das wollen wir damit
ausdrücken und natürlich kommt dazu auch
eine gute test strategie die auch von
den ländern vorbereitet
wird oder schon durchgeführt wird also
das sind die dinge die ich noch ergänzen
[Musik]
nein nein das die freiheit gilt weiter
das impfangebot gemacht weil nein das
ist nicht der sachverhalt sondern es
wird den grundschullehrerinnen und
erzieherin ein angebot gemacht und zwar
früher als wir dieses angebot hätten
machen können wenn es jetzt in der
jetzigen priorisierung geblieben wäre
und das werden wird man bei der
fortschreibung der nächsten im
verordnung dann der berücksichtigen ich
trinke heute ist der frau
bundeskanzlerin ich hätte ganz gern noch
mal zur eröffnungs perspektive für den
handel gefragt also den nächsten schritt
jetzt steht hier in dem papier man muss
seine stabile 7 tages incidents von
höchstens 35 nachweisen was heißt denn
eine stabile incidents muss man dann
eine woche diesen wert erreicht haben
oder welcher zeitraum zählt da und an
die beiden länder vertreter die frage
wie wollen sie dann sicherstellen dass
wenn ein land öffnet nicht die bewohner
des anderen landes dann doch diesen
shopping tourismus machen also werden
dann innerdeutschen grenzen gesperrt
oder wie soll das funktionieren
wir haben sieben tage incident
unterschiedlich definiert mindestens
drei tage sage ich mal irgendwas
zwischen fünf und drei tagen oder drei
und fünf tagen sollte es sein ein
anderes also sie können mal davon
ausgehen mindestens drei tage bis zu der
zu der abstimmung zwischen den ländern
kann ich sagen dass wir das alle
miteinander betont haben dass wir das
natürlich genau nicht wurden diesen
shopping tourismus und dass es
mindestens immer in den benachbarten
ländern dazu auch eine verständigung
geben muss wir kommen ja jetzt doch in
großen schritten gemeinsam in die phasen
wo wir überhaupt über solche dinge
nachdenken können wo die instanzen für
die länder insgesamt nach unten gehen
und
ganz selbstverständlich wieder unser
beispiel wenn ich in berlin was
beschließe in richtung einzelhandel muss
ich mich mit dietmar wolke abstimmen und
umgekehrt alles andere wäre daher auch
ein fataler weg den wir auch vermeiden
wollen also es ist ganz klar dass die
konkreten schritte der eröffnung dann
zwischen den benachbarten ländern
mindestens zwischen den benachbarten
ländern abgestimmt werden das wurde
heute auch ausdrücklich von allen noch
mal festhalten
na ja dass man einfach die idee die in
zeitpunkt mit entsprechend miteinander
abstimmen das ist doch das entscheiden
und das haben wir auch in der hand über
unsere verordnung
das machen wir im übrigen auch jetzt
schon ist er kein hexenwerk
wenn wir jetzt reden über die situation
an den schulen rolle als wir gesprochen
haben über dinge im sport oder so da
haben wir uns doch immer zwischen berlin
und brandenburg abgestimmt und ich
vermute das tun alle anderen
bundesländer genauso und kommt zu einer
weitestgehenden verständigung und
alleine das ist doch der entscheidende
punkt dass wir abstimmen dann machen wir
was auf und für welche bereiche wenn es
nur das wäre sehr stark daran arbeiten
sollten dass wir möglichst ein
einheitliches band bilden in den
instanzen bei den bundesländern und dem
sind wir ja sehr viel näher gekommen als
wir das mal vor geraumer zeit waren und
dazu ist auch der punkt 7 in unserem
beschluss noch mal von bedeutung nämlich
dass in ländern bzw landkreisen die
aufgrund ihrer hohen 7 tages incidents
die inzidenz von 50 nicht unterschreiten
können besondere weitere lokale und
regionale maßnahmen implementiert werden
können eingeführt werden können
mit nämlich das ganze bundesgebiet alle
16 bundesländer möglich sein wenn eine
sehr vergleichbare instanz das wird nie
genau gleich sein aber wenn sie mal
denken es gibt durchaus länder wie herr
müller schon gesagt hat berlin stand mal
an einer ganz anderen stelle in der
reihenfolge der länder ist jetzt sehr
nach vorne gerückt das kann sehr schnell
gehen bayern genauso also amisen
fortschritte erzielt berlin/osnabrück
frau merkel ich möchte gern noch mal
nach der vom 30 incidents fragen und war
würde mich interessieren wenn sie dann
in reichweite kommen die 35er inzidenz
ob man sich darauf verlassen kann dass
das team nicht weiter angehoben wird auf
20 oder 10 und wie diese 235 ja jetzt
auf einmal zum zum maßstab aller dinge
geworden ist die sich zum maßstab aller
dinge geworden sondern wenn sie den
fahrer auf den 28 jahr des
infektionsschutzgesetzes schauen dann
haben wir dort zwei zahlen genannt
einmal die 50 dass die es sozusagen die
zahl an der die wirklich
weitreichendsten maßnahmen getroffen
werden weil man davon ausgehen muss dass
da eine hohe wahrscheinlichkeit besteht
dass die kontakt nach verfolgung nicht
mehr möglich ist
aber es gibt auch eine zweite zahl in
diesem § 28a weitreichende maßnahmen
noch gelten nämlich die 35 einfach aus
der erfahrung heraus wenn man in einem
exponentiellen wachstum ist das der weg
von 35 auf 50 nicht weit ist und das ist
beiden ziffern sind genannt beide zahlen
dürfen nicht das ende der fahnenstange
sein ich will daran erinnern dass wir im
letzten jahr im sommer als wir doch
vergleichsweise zu der heutigen
situation unbeschwerter leben konnten
wir instanzen unterhalb von 10 hatten
also endlich den gesamten sommer
zwischen knapp drei und dann zum ende
des sommers vielleicht acht neun oder so
was habe ich jetzt nicht genau im blick
aber acht oder neuen gedanken und
da war sozusagen die kontrolle das
infektionsgeschehen es durch die
gesundheitsämter sehr sehr gut möglich
die würde heute besser möglichst rennen
weil die infektions weil die
gesundheitsämter aufgestockt sind weil
wir mehr digitalisierung haben ganz
andere erfahrungen
wir haben die korona waren app dazu wir
haben testmöglichkeiten so dass man
sicherlich auch mehr machen kann aber
das ist die voraussetzung das heißt wir
dürfen uns auf gar keinen fall mit einer
seitwärtsbewegung dann bei 35 zufrieden
geben weil dann die die umkehr dass bei
weiteren öffnung sofort wieder
exponentielles wachstum beginnt schon
sehr wahrscheinlich sein kann und durch
die mutation wo er ja noch gar nichts
wissen und auch gar kein gefühl haben
kann das noch mal beschleunigt werden
natürlich ersetzen und zwar diese 30 ist
nicht nur in den paragrafen oder 35er
genannt sondern sie hat ja auch sonst in
unserer pandemie bekämpfung eine rolle
gespielt ich glaube wir beide herr söder
und dich in der phase wo er die 50
bundesweit als wahre zahl genannt wurde
haben wir gesagt für unsere länder
wollen wir schon die 30 35 aufgreifen
von wo abwehr besonderen maßnahmen
ergreifen
das heißt es ist in einigen
bundesländern auch gelernt dass dann
noch mal eine wichtige grenze eingezogen
ist wir haben ja bayern und berlin
gesagt alles was darüber es ist ein
problem
und jetzt können wir genauso umgekehrt
natürlich auch sagen ja wir wollen
weitergehen aber die 30 die 35
ermöglicht uns wiederum auch über neue
dinge nachzudenken
diese zahl ist nicht aus der luft
gegriffen die es in vielen bereichen
auch gelernt über die letzten monate
auch deshalb ist sie überhaupt ins
infektionsschutzgesetz geklärt jörg
blank dpa
bundeskanzler ich möchte ich ganz gerne
nochmal auf den die impfung für die
erzieher und für die lehrer zu sprechen
kommen wann rechnen sie denn damit dass
die tatsächlich geimpft werden kann
diese gruppe noch vor der sommerpause
weil im moment steht ja bei weitem nicht
genug impfstoff zur verfügung und herr
söder ganz kurz sie machen ja ein
gesicht heute als wenn sie etwas fünf
tagen wintersturm kommen
sie haben sich mit ihrem vorsichtigen
kurs bei den schulen ja nicht
durchsetzen können heute irgendwo
fürchten sie dass in vier wochen hier
sitzen und dann sagen müssen hätten wir
dann doch die schule nicht so schnell
auf gemacht also glaube ich dass wir
sagen können dass die gruppe 2 im
wesentlichen ich habe das jetzt nicht
ganz genau ausgerechnet aber angesichts
der angekündigten ins mengen vor der
sommerpause waren immer die in den
bundesländern beginnt zumindest die
erste impfung bekommen kann ja das würde
ich so sagen ich meine es ist eine große
gruppe das muss man sehen
von mehr als einer million menschen und
deutlich mehr als einer million menschen
aber ich glaube es hat auch seine
berechtigung und ist auch als ein signal
der anerkennung für die arbeit die dort
geleistet wird gedacht also erst einmal
blank wundert nicht dass sie sich über
mein gesicht zu sagen ich freue mich
aber dass ich es genau beobachten
übrigens haben wir ziemlich schwer und
winter wenn ich das sagen darf also
bekam jetzt eine person an starken tagen
irgendwie vor mich hin lächeln
die lage ist doch nicht unserem land
ernst und die stimmungslage der menschen
ist nicht nur gespannt ist auch sehr
gesagt ziemlich so ist die menschen ist
jetzt alles ohne ohne ohne beschwerden
und das erste des 2 also ich glaube
heute hat sich das vorsichtige kurs
durchgesetzt und zwar richtig
und ich bin auch dankbar dass alle den
mitgegangen sind es gab pks da gab es
eine wesentlich größere spannbreite
zwischen denen die sehr lockern wollten
und denen den vorsichtigen kurs gefahren
haben wir haben heute wenn wir ehrlich
sind wir mit einmal andiskutiert weil
wir halt ein florales gremiums sind und
wo jeder auch noch mal auf seine
position verdeutlicht aber so in ordnung
ist und seine situation bescheid
aber wenn sie jetzt genau die punkte
sehen friseure nicht über nacht die
schulen deutlich gemacht dass jeder
seine entscheidung treffen kann
übrigens ist es bei den schulen erfüllt
mich ganz so mit dem flickenteppich weil
schule ist immer ländersache
die leute empfinden ist auch so also
jemand den beinen der schule geht dem
ist es nicht so wichtig was in berlin
passiert und wahrscheinlich auch
umgekehrt wer schaut auf seine
schulorganisation da sind ja auch die
schul termine an dass zum beispiel aber
ist ein ganz anderer zeitpunkt dennis
mehr und ich bin ehrlich sein mit dem
ergebnis schon sehr zufrieden und ich
finde es deswegen vor allem gut weil wir
bei der frage perspektiven vorsicht die
vorsicht nicht vergessen haben
und ich glaube die letzten tage haben
die öffentlichen debatte so verfolgt da
gab es ja nur noch stimme gefordert
haben auch machen aufmachen aufmachen
und wir sind der versuchung widerstanden
allein einer stimmung nachzugeben
sondern die erwartung der menschen in
die richtige balance zu der sorge vor
der möglichen entwicklung zu setzen so
bin ich schon sehr zufrieden dass die
sitzung heute mehr endlos dauern
wir sagen uns jetzt mal wir machen es
etwas kürzer und das ist eine der
wenigen versprechen die wir uns schwer
tun umzusetzen
ja aber nicht oft also fliegt habe
einmal ein mal was länger aber wir
hatten auch schon kürzere sitzungen und
die länge bestimmten automatisch die
qualität aber das ist egal ist alles gut
heute
wir schaffen hier noch zwei kurze fragen
frank jordan sap
frau bundeskanzlerin mit der neuen
variante steigt die gefahr einer neuen
welle ja nicht nur in deutschland
sondern weltweit
ich sehe aber in ihrem heutigen
beschlüssen nichts was sich auf die
europäischen bemühungen bezieht
koordiniert in der pandemie vorzugehen
wurde was zumindest diskutiert der
ministerpräsident hat ja schon auf die
problematik der fälle direkt hinter der
grenze angesprochen und vermittelt die
maßnahmen in den schulen mit lüftern und
tests wurden ja schon im frühling
vorgeschlagen
wie wollen sie in knapp zwei wochen
schaffen was sie in zehn monaten nicht
geschafft haben also es wurde heute
nicht weitgehend diskutiert weil wir
dass corinna kabinett und an vielen
anderen stellen die lateral auch mit den
betroffenen bundesländern sehr sehr viel
diskutieren
stärkere kontrollen zu österreich die
innenminister beider länder haben
telefoniert
wir haben alle mit dem bundeskanzler
kurz telefoniert unsere besorgnis auch
deutlich gemacht gerade bezüglich der
südafrikanischen mutation in tirol was
ja nun sehr dicht an der bayerischen
grenze liegt und wir sind also in dem
zusammenhang sehr viel unterwegs aber
das war heute nicht gegenstand unserer
diskussion mit allen bundesländern
aber sie kennen die einreise verordnung
sie wissen dass wir jedes wochenende
also in freitag darüber entscheiden wer
wird mutations gebiet und das bedeutet
natürlich auch dann beförderungsverbot
für die luftfahrtgesellschaften und
ähnliches mehr
und wir gucken uns natürlich auch genau
die situation in unseren nachbarländern
am zum beispiel hat sich in polen die
situation sehr verbessert wir haben
jetzt durchaus vergleichbare instanzen
während der bruch zur tschechischen
republik also die unterschiede in der
residenz schon noch gravierend sind und
wenn man sich die landfahrer in
deutschland anschaut sieht man auch dass
das natürlich nicht und auffällig bei
den deutschen landkreisen in der
grenzregion ankommt sondern dass sie
dadurch durchaus beeinflusst sind
und hier muss man immer wieder gucken
und gerade bayern das davon sehr
betroffen auch sachsen zum teil und dem
wird schon sehr viel aufmerksamkeit aber
diskussion gewidmet aber heute war es
nicht thema unserer besprechen
zu ihrer frage mit den mit der situation
an den schulen kann man sagen wir haben
im frühjahr nicht nur dinge angekündigt
oder als möglichkeiten formuliert
sondern wir haben angefangen sie
umzusetzen und alle die mich kennen
wissen dass ich mir manche schneller
wünsche und auch in berlin manche
schneller wünsche rede ich nicht drum
rum aber ich kann mir manche dinge auch
nicht herbei beschließen
als wir im frühjahr über den verstärkten
einsatz von tests für lehrerinnen und
lehrer gesprochen haben gab es nur
begrenzt kapazitäten
erinnern sie sich bitte daran dass hier
eine große debatte hatten wo und wie wir
die am besten einsetzen ob in den
krankenhäusern oder in dem pflegeheim
oder in den schulen
wir waren weit davon entfernt zu sagen
wir können sie überall gleichermaßen
einsetzen und wir haben in der phase
schon begonnen über die charité mit
mobilen teams die schulen und kitas
anzufahren und eine test strategie zu
entwickeln und dann auch schrittweise
immer mehr tests anzubieten
bis zu dem punkt dann auch wenn man
gesagt hat so jetzt sind ausreichend da
wo es dann konkrete anlaufpunkte gab für
lehrerinnen und lehrer wo man hingehen
konnte und sich testen lassen konnte und
das wird jetzt wieder weiterentwickelt
und wir gehen damit konkret mit
kapazitäten an die schulen
wir haben für berlin haben wir uns jetzt
größenordnung besichert schon für die
nächste phase der tests dieser
vereinfachten tests oder selbst test-
oder wie auch immer man sie nennt und
man muss auch berücksichtigen dass
wiederum an den selbst oder schnelltests
ja dann weitere tests folgen hängen dort
wo es positive ergebnisse gibt müssen
sie nachverfolgt werden wiederum über
pcr tests und laborkapazitäten über den
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst und und
und also insofern ja das ein oder andere
hätte vielleicht auch noch schneller
gehen können aber es waren keine
ankündigung im frühjahr die jetzt erst
umgesetzt werden sondern sind
ankündigung gewesen die schrittweise
hochgefahren wurden bis zu dem punkt
jetzt auch was belüftungssysteme
anbelangt wir haben schon hunderte an
den berliner schulen und es kommen noch
weitere 100 auch da gilt richtig
vielleicht hätte auch etwas früher sein
können aber wir beginnen nicht jetzt
kristina dunz dpa eine kurze letzte
frage ob bundeskanzlerin schon bei der
letzten mpk stand dieser passus drin
dass sie eine öffnung strategie vorlegen
wollen
die sicher und gerecht ist das steht
jetzt wieder drin wie unzufrieden sind
sie dass diese strategie noch nicht
entwickelt wurde und wie werden sie auf
die enttäuschung genau der bereiche dann
eingehen wie gastronomie sport und
kultur wann soll diese arbeitsgruppe die
angekündigt ist die arbeit vorlegen
wir werden natürlich am dritten märz
darauf zurückkommen aber ich gehöre zu
denen die glauben dass eine solche
öffnung strategie eine gute mischung
sein muss aus vorhersehbarkeit und
planbarkeit für bestimmte bereiche aber
auch aus flexibilität wir haben noch nie
über ganz viele monate sagen können wie
genau sich die dinge entwickeln
wir haben alle bereiche hier aufgeführt
auch in einer reihenfolge die durchaus
etwas mit öffnungen zu tun haben könnte
aber wenn sie das genau lesen und die
werden auch beim nächsten mal eine rolle
spielen aber bis ins letzte jetzt
vorauszusagen die sich die dinge
entwickeln das halte ich auch für sehr
schwierig und deshalb können wir haben
wir heute etwas stilbildendes gemacht
wir haben nämlich den ersten konkreten
größeren öffnungs schritt jetzt mal von
der schule und friseur abgesehen mit
einer instanz verknüpft und dieses
stilbildende wünsche ich mir auch
beizubehalten weil das ist das was
wichtig ist wobei man andere faktoren
auch betrachten muss aber ganz wichtig
ist eben immer die nachverfolgbarkeit in
die wir wieder zurück kommen müssen der
kontakte und jetzt werden wir auch
erfahrungen warum mit den
gesundheitsämtern wie sind die jetzt
aufgestellt wie wird die korona waren
aber wir waren jetzt in einem solchen
exponentiellen wachstum dass so ein
diffuses infektionsgeschehen da war das
sowieso nichts mehr richtig nachverfolgt
werden konnte wenn aber wieder weniger
fälle da sind ich meine was markus söder
gesagt hat 90 prozent weniger
infektionen
dann werden wir auch wieder einen ganz
anderen überblick bekommen und dann wird
auch sozusagen werden die tests
strategien werden wieder mehr angewandt
und das glaube ich gelingt uns und je
nachdem wir uns das gelingt werden wir
auch wieder ein gefühl bekommen dann
kannst du den nächsten eröffnungs
schritt fahren und deshalb wäre das
vollkommen verfrüht jetzt gewesen zu
sagen bei 30 mache ich das und bei 29
mache ich das sondern das muss man jetzt
mal gucken wie sich die dinge weiter
entwickeln wir haben diese große
unsicherheit mit der mutation denn das
muss man ganz klar sagen sie wird die
oberhand gewinnt das alte virus wird
verschwinden wir werden mit einem neuen
virus leben und dieses neue virus und
sein verhalten können wir noch nicht
einschätzen
und wenn wir nicht eine bessere
nachverfolgbarkeit bekommt dann kann es
ganz schnell passieren dass wir wieder
ein exponentielles wachstum kommt man
deshalb müssen wir so vorsichtig sein
wie das ja hier auch gesagt wurde und
deshalb müssen wir weiter runter runter
und damit der fall sei dank an alle
dankeschön
tja so weit also die pressekonferenz aus
berlin liebe zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer der lock down wird verlängert
bis 73
aber und über dieses aber möchte ich
gleich ausführlich sprechen mit unserer
hauptstadt korrespondent in nicole
diekmann in berlin wird rüsseln das
gleich miteinander auf was denn trotz
der verlängerung möglich sein könnte in
den nächsten wochen und bevor wir das
machen fassen wir das noch mal zusammen
die beschlüsse die wir da gerade gehört
haben heiko kunzmann hat das für uns
vorbereitet
seit dem nachmittag haben die kanzlerin
und die ministerpräsidenten der
bundesländer beraten beim corona gipfel
und darauf haben sie sich geeinigt
der showdown wird verlängert bis zum
siebten märz private treffen sind
weiterhin nur in sehr kleinem rahmen
möglich kitas und schulen können
schrittweise geöffnet werden wir haben
die länder freie hand der bildung
ländersache ist
friseure können wieder öffnen am ersten
märz unter strengen hygiene auflagen
weitere lockerungen sollen erst ab einer
sieben tage inzidenz von 35 oder weniger
neuerkrankungen pro 100000 einwohner
beschlossen werden etwa für handel
gastronomie oder museen
tja so weit also die beschlüsse nicole
wenn ich mir angucke was hier in den
chats so passiert und auch da fordere
ich noch mal dazu auf sehr gerne
mitmachen fragen kommentare schreiben in
die kommentarspalten oder wenn ihr und
sie die zdf- heute- app nutzt bitte an
diese e mail adresse beziehungsweise an
die email-adresse bestimmt alle schon
kennt weil sie jetzt gerade jetzt ist
sie zu sehen
genau wir freuen uns also über ihre und
eure teilnahme und das was wir bis jetzt
hier lesen ist nicole viel unverständnis
über die öffnung der friseursalons da
kommt also ganz viele fragen zum
beispiel von jasmin pinkert über youtube
friseure sind wichtiger als andere wo
gibt es denn da eine werteskala
unverschämt weg für lich und das andere
ist die frage warum 35 jetzt das neue 50
ist also warum der inzidenz wert
abgesenkt worden ist ich würde gerne mal
bei den friseursalons bleiben
auch wenn das jetzt natürlich eine
kleine gruppe betrifft und
vergleichsweise eine entscheidung ist
die nicht so wahnsinnig viele menschen
betrifft zumindest was das gewerbe
angeht aber nicole warum hat man sich
dafür entschieden die ab erster
märzwoche zu öffnen die offizielle
begründung ist jetzt das friseursalons
als wie heißt das so schön körpernah
dienstleister definiert werden sollen es
gab dazu eine äußerung vom
bundesinnenminister horst seehofer ich
glaube in der vergangenen woche der
sagte na ja der schwarzmarkt blüht und
also ich kann für mich sagen das was ich
so aus dem freundes- und bekanntenkreis
höre es stimmt damit überein also man
hat er wahrscheinlich jetzt eine
mischung gesucht und man musste heute
irgendetwas verkünden man fühlte sich
wahnsinnig unter druck
so ein bonbon zu geben wenn man das so
formulieren will ja also irgendwie auch
positives signal zu senden
und ich glaube das ist so dass das
konglomerat an argumenten das dazu
geführt hat jetzt zumindest darauf zu
machen
unter wahrung sehr strenger hygiene
konzepte die genau den kommentar habe
ich auch gerade gelesen dass man dass
man sagt warum läuft doch sowieso alles
schwarz also quasi das zitat von herrn
seehofer was du gerade genannt hast
kommt hier im chat auch auf youtube
schreibt großmann man macht friseure auf
die so nah am menschen sind aber
baumärkte nicht das ist ein widerspruch
dann kommen wir mal zu dem nächsten was
darin ja auch steckt nämlich
einzelhandel baumärkte weiß ich jetzt
ehrlich gesagt ich habe ich nie nicht
detailliert in diesem papier aufgeführt
gelesen wenn du da was anderes weist
gerne aber reden wir über den
einzelhandel ab einer inzidenz von 35
soll der einzelhandel wieder
schrittweise öffnen können und andere
branchen auch kannst du noch mal
erklären warum jetzt 35 und nicht mehr
ja das war ein großes thema heute es
gibt einmal das hat angela merkel dann
erklärt im infektionsschutzgesetz auf
die frage eine rolle
denn die da von einer willkürlichen zahl
sprach der sagte angela merkel das ist
nicht willkürlich diese zeit findet sich
im infektionsschutzgesetz es gibt einmal
die 50 die ist uns allen ja hinlänglich
bekannt das bisher immer lockerungen in
aussicht gestellt wurden und auch
angestrebt wurde diese maximale inzidenz
von 50 zu erreichen weil so die
argumentation dann die gesundheitsämter
wieder die infektionsketten vernünftig
nachverfolgen könnten die 35er so sagte
dass eben markus söder der
ministerpräsident von bayern und
stellvertretender spd-vorsitzender ich
habe mir das notiert die zahl 35 ist neu
da wird es sicherlich auch kritik daran
geben ja aber sie ist eine vorsichtige
benchmark mit hinblick auf die
mutationen also das damit erklärt er
diese abwendung von der 50 hin zur
strengeren 35 und das sagte angela
merkel auch in dem eingangs statement
das ist das unter dem licht unter dem
eindruck dieser drohenden dritten welle
durch die virusvarianten die ja
existieren vor allem den aus südafrika
und großbritannien will man jetzt noch
vorsichtiger sein zumindest was die
öffnung von allem jenseits von
friseursalons schulen und kitas betrifft
genau sie hat ja auch gesagt die
nächsten wochen sind entscheidend oder
existenziell um diese mutation irgendwie
im griff zu halten
nochmal zwar meinungen hier gaby wilken
schreibt über facebook echt übel die
sieben tage incidents musste bis dato
unter 50 sein die haben wir jetzt
erreicht jetzt müssen sie auf einmal
unter 35 sein und ebenfalls dazu auf
youtube schreibt martin hochrad wenn die
35 erreicht ist kommt die 20 je nachdem
wie sich die mutation entwickelt hältst
du das für ein denkbares szenario das
man da noch mal reagiert und die zahl
nochmal senkt naja das
wurde jetzt auch gerade in der
pressekonferenz gefragt
da ist die antwort immer wieder von
seiten der politik wir kennen die
entwicklung noch nicht uns ist es in den
letzten fast zwölf monaten immer
unmöglich gewesen die entwicklung der
folgenden wochen vorher zu sagen also
ich würde mal sagen ich halte nichts für
unmöglich
das haben wir gelernt in den letzten
zwölf monaten auf youtube schreibt ein
user namens niederrheiner shopping
tourismus let's go
dazu würde ich ganz gerne mal hier auf
das notebook gucken und sehen die zdf
heute hat er immer die sieben tage ins
tendenz auf den auf ihrer seite und hier
kann man zum beispiel sehen und das ist
jetzt ein sehr plakatives beispiel aber
der landkreis oldenburg in niedersachsen
hat 34 fälle je 100.000 einwohner und
direkt daneben der landkreis vechta hat
203 fälle je 100.000 einwohner
wie will man denn verhindern nicole dass
es tatsächlich menschen gibt die dann
aus vechta nach oldenburg zum shoppen
fahren oder zum friseur oder was auch
immer
ja das ist eine gute frage
die frage ist eben ob man das dann
tatsächlich in der realität verhindern
kann
michael müller vorsitzender der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz hat auf die
frage bezogen auf die bundesländer und
hier in berlin zum beispiel ist es ja
wir haben ja grosse nähe zu brandenburg
ja das sind ja teilweise nur ein paar
kilometer je nachdem wo man in berlin
wohnt da sagte er die länder stimmen
sich da untereinander ab ob die
landkreise das dann auch tun ja also
dieses klein-klein schwierig stelle ich
mir sehr sehr schwierig vor
dann werfen wir mal einen blick auf die
schulen da fragt über youtube sabo
ärztin wie lange sind die schulen zu
nicole tja also zu den schulen ist erst
mal zu sagen das war ein bemerkenswerter
moment heute in dieser pressekonferenz
als angela merkel
sehr freimütig einräumte dass sie quasi
die waffen gestreckt hat das jetzt also
die länder freie hand haben zu
entscheiden wann und wie öffnen sie die
schulen und sie hat das begründet mit
ich habe als bundeskanzlerin kein
vetorecht ich kann es nicht durchsetzen
sie hat auch völlig unverblümt gesagt
ich war für den ersten märz aber wir
leben im föderalismus so das zeigt zum
einen eine machtlosigkeit ja einer
kanzlerin deren amtszeit auch demnächst
endet die nicht wieder antritt deswegen
kann man das vielleicht ein bisschen
freimütiger einräumen das ist aber
umgekehrt gedacht ist das auch die
aussage
zoe ministerpräsident innen watt euch da
in teilen anscheinend oder wat euch in
teilen mit mir nicht eigentlich eh bald
schneller die schulen öffnen dann macht
mal aber ich gehe auf distanz zu euch
hier öffentlich wenn das schiefgeht ich
habe euch gewarnt
es gibt jetzt die ersten daten die auf
den tisch legen welche müller hat es
eben gesagt am 22 februar soll es sie in
berlin stufenweise wieder losgehen und
auch in sachsen
wir hatten eben hier im zdf spezial den
sächsischen ministerpräsidenten michael
kretschmer
da will man schon nächste woche anfangen
zu lockern aber das gehört natürlich
auch dazu michael müller hat dazu nichts
gesagt aber in sachsen soll die
schulpflicht trotzdem weiter ausgesetzt
bleiben das heißt man schiebt jetzt die
verantwortung den eltern zu geben sie
ihre kinder in die schule und haben ein
schlechtes gewissen weil dadurch das
infektionsrisiko steigt oder lassen sie
es zu hause und haben ein schlechtes
gewissen weil ihre kinder unterricht
verpassen den anschluss verpassen und
auch zeit mit gleichaltrigen verpassen
und stellt die schulen vor die
herausforderungen unterricht zu machen
für kinder die in der not betreuung sind
kinder die in der präsenz in der schule
sind und kinder die von zu hause
unterrichtet werden wie das
funktionieren soll
dazu wären wir bestimmt auch einige
streams hier machen die das thema schule
wird natürlich auch hier sehr kontrovers
diskutiert und zwei fragen
kommen dazu auch per mail von mali kh
mano von werden denn die konkreten
zeitpunkt für schul öffnungen speziell
für bayern bekannt gegeben und wird es
sonderregelungen für hot spots geben und
auch auf youtube fragt ein gaming dann
werden sich die bundesländer äußern was
einige gerade schon genannt bei den
anderen ist davon auszugehen dass die
sich morgen oder übermorgen äußern
werden müssen denn ab montag braucht sie
eine rolle neue regelung in jedem der 16
bundesländer oder ist er außer sachsen
schon irgendwo klar wie es weitergehen
soll
nee wie ich gerade gesagt habe hier in
berlin da hatte jetzt michael müller
natürlich auch weil er gerade in der
pressekonferenz saß die möglichkeit dass
schon zu zu verkünden quasi aber ja also
natürlich werden sich die
ministerpräsidentin möglichst schnell
dazu äußern
eltern brauchen auch ein bisschen
planungssicherheit und die schulen
fallen dinge auch schulleiter innen und
auch lehrer innen die müssen ja wissen
was in den nächsten tagen auf sie
zukommt nun hat man ja immer in dieser
runde sehr auf wissenschaftliche
expertise gesetzt und nun hat müller
gerade gesagt es gibt bei den kindern
keine unterschiede was das
infektionsgeschehen angeht wenn wir nach
großbritannien blicken dann hat man
schon das gefühl dass es der
wissenschaftler gibt es gibt sehr wohl
unterschiede bei diesen mutationen denn
es sind mehr kinder betroffen und das
wiederum könnte die schulen in den
nächsten entscheidenden wochen wie sie
die kanzlerin hier dargestellt hat
möglicherweise doch zu hotspots machen
hast du das gefühl dass man sich dieser
gefahr bewusst es aber trotzdem in
abwägung all der anderen aspekte die man
bedenken muss sich wohl wissen trotzdem
für diesen schritt entschieden hat und
jetzt hofft dass es gut geht
du hast das glaube ich das schlüsselwort
gerade genannt abwägungen das ist jetzt
natürlich auch nicht blinder eifer
ausschließlich von 16
ministerpräsidentinnen die die sich
beliebt machen wollen bei eltern die im
home office arbeiten und gleichzeitig
homeschooling zum beispiel organisieren
müssen das hat michael kretschmer eben
auch hier bei uns im zdf spezial gesagt
es ist immer eine abwägung zwischen
infektionsrisiko und dem risiko
psychischer probleme die kinder und
jugendliche durch diesen
unterrichtsausfall durch das den
fehlenden kontakt zu gleichaltrigen
durch das fehlen von erfolgserlebnissen
und so weiter ja durchaus auch haben
können so ist es schon aber es ist
schwierig es ist kompliziert es ist auf
der einen seite eben die öffnung von
schulen und kindergärten die jetzt
anstehen und auf der anderen seite sehen
wie ihr mann wird jetzt strenger und
nächste lockerungen werden erst ab einer
inzidenz von 35 angela merkel sagte eben
auf nachfrage nach drei tagen wenn es
eine stabile inzidenz bundesweit gibt
von 35 über mindestens drei tage dann
könnte man über weitere lockerungen
nachdenken das passt auf den ersten
blick nicht zusammen aber es sind eben
immer viele varianten viele variablen
mit denen da gearbeitet wird
wir lesen gerade die eilmeldung die dpa
meldet dass armin laschet der
ministerpräsident von
nordrhein-westfalen verkündet dass er
erst ab dem 22
februar schrittweise die schulen wieder
öffnen möchte und sich dabei auch mit
hessen niedersachsen und rheinland-pfalz
abstimmen wird also in diesen
bundesländern sieht es so aus als würden
die schulen erst ab dem 22
wieder geöffnet und in welcher form ob
wechsel und distanz unterricht das wird
man in der genauen ausgestaltung sich
dann auch noch mal angucken müssen wir
haben schon oft über die studentinnen
gesprochen weil das unsere userinnen und
user auch umtreibt
auch nach dieser pressekonferenz haben
wir gelernt da gibt es nichts neues oder
gibt es da irgendwelche signale
ich habe keine silbe in dieser
pressekonferenz dazu gehört und würde
mal überhaupt
habe sehr aufmerksam gelauscht ich weiß
nicht ob es jeder anders gegangen ist
ging mir genauso
was allerdings aufgefallen ist das hilft
den studentinnen jetzt zwar überhaupt
gar nicht weiter weil sie nun mal nicht
in der schule situation sind und auch
nicht in der arbeitssituation sondern
dazwischen was nicht aber hat auch
forschen lassen war tatsächlich die idee
die angela merkel dann in den fragen
hinten auch nochmal erwähnt hat dass man
lehrer und erzieher anfängt zu impfen
mit einer früheren priorisierung und je
nachdem welche impfstoffe wie verfügbar
sind könnte es sein dass vor den
sommerferien auch erste impfung
tatsächlich schon stattfinden können wie
hoffnungsvoll und wie realistisch stimmt
dich das auch da haben wir es wieder mit
vielen variablen zu tun das klang ja
auch gerade in der pressekonferenz an
der impfstoff muss erstmal da sein es
muss genug impfstoff da sein um angela
merkel sprach von mehr als einer million
menschen so viel so hoch ist die zahl
ungefähr die erzieher/innen und
lehrer/innen in deutschland umfasst
impfen zu können so sie es denn alle
wollen
und die frage ist ja auch wo fehlten
stoff dann es wird ja da nicht
zusätzliche impfstoff besorgt wenn das
so einfach ginge hätten wir hier ganz
andere diskussionen und vielleicht auch
eine ganz andere lockerungs debatte also
die die prioritäten müssen dann neu
geordnet werden die gruppen müssen dann
neu geordnet werden im impfplan von
bundesgesundheitsministerin sparen also
die idee kommt ja auch relativ spät an
dem tag an dem auch über schule
öffnungen geredet wird wird das dann
auch konkretisiert also der plan ist da
aber sagen wir mal bis zu den
sommerferien vergeht noch eine menge
zeit und bis dahin gehen auch wieder
viele mädchen und jungen in die schule
und in die kita nicole eine sache die
wiederum gar nicht besprochen wurde ist
die nach grenzschließungen dazu würde
ich gleich auch noch mal kommen weil es
dazu auch einen kommentar gibt ein
statement aber noch von nele punkt über
facebook noch mal zu den tests für
lehrerin
und lehrer moment jetzt moment noch mal
auf anfang wir haben gerade über
impfungen für lehrerinnen und lehrer
gesprochen das könnte eine perspektive
sein bevor wir über mögliche
grenzschließungen reden über die gar
nicht gesprochen wurde was ich
interessant finde
reden wir über tests für lehrerinnen und
lehrer dann auch darüber wurde ja
gesprochen michael müller aus berlin hat
gesagt da haben wir anfangen der
pandemie das gewollt und nicht gekonnt
und jetzt können wir es jetzt ist nur
die frage wie es gemacht wird
nele punkt über facebook schreibt
endlich mal eine vernünftige idee mehr
tests mit lehrerinnen erzieherinnen
durchzuführen um schule und kita zu
ermöglichen das sollte die oberste
priorität haben
wie realistisch ist das denn mit den
obersten prioritäten ist das immer so
eine sache das hängt natürlich auch
immer vom blickwinkel ab ja man versucht
das jetzt ist gab ihr ein pilotprojekt
das ist schon vor vielen wochen in
berlin zumindest angelaufen tatsächlich
test zur verfügung zu stellen
für fc erinnern an den kitas aber auch
diese tests braucht man die kosten auch
geld und da würde ich gerne bei mir das
auch noch mal aufgefallen ist auf einen
anderen punkt in dieser pressekonferenz
zu sprechen kommen nämlich auf die
selbsttests die werden ja auch in diesem
papier jetzt erwähnt und ich glaube es
war michael müller der sie eben auch
noch einmal erwähnt hat das wird ja
schon länger gefordert dass mehr
möglichkeiten geschaffen werden dass
leute sich selbst zu hause testen können
was aber heute kein thema waren wir
erinnern uns das ist in der vergangenen
nach der vergangenen ministerpräsidentin
dem konferenz auch dann zum thema
geworden da ging es um ffp 2 und
medizinische massen die seitdem nicht
sind in geschäften und in öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln wie sollen die
finanziert werden also anders rum
gesprochen was sollen die kosten wie
teuer sind die und was ist mit den
leuten die sich das nicht leisten können
also diese selbst fest die müssten dann
der theoretisch vorsichtiger sein als
diejenigen die die bezahlen können und
dann entspannter rausgehen unter
menschen gehen
also da finde ich und das finde ich
wichtig dass man mal zu erwähnen ist ein
großes fragezeichen heute abend
geblieben und das ist ja auch bei den
friseuren so ein thema gewesen man
könnte ja auch sagen macht die friseure
auf aber man muss irgendwie die friseure
verpflichten die kunden zu testen oder
die kunden müssen sich testen bevor sie
zum friseur gehen aber das ist ja
dasselbe problem was du gerade
angesprochen hast dann greife ich die
frage jetzt tatsächlich von emma über
youtube auf die schreibt hof ist der
schlimmste landkreis wegen der grenze zu
tschechien was möchte man da machen
obwohl es der schlimmste landkreis ist
das müssen wir noch mal checken aber
natürlich sieht man die mutation breitet
sich nicht nur in deutschland aus auch
in österreich wir haben die diskussion
gerade mit tirol tirol abregeln ja oder
nein
was machen die bayern mit der grenze zu
österreich das ist ja schon ein thema
aber heute abend war es keins heute
abend hat man offenbar tatsächlich wie
du sagst das gefühl gehabt man muss mehr
über perspektiven reden als über neue
einschränkungen ganz genau das ist das
signal das von heute abend ausgehen
sollte also einmal die dritte welle ist
angelegt so hat es die kanzlerin eben
formuliert eben durch die mutationen die
langfristig wie sie aussagte die
überhand gewinnen die oberhand gewinnen
werden sagt irgendwann werden die neuen
varianten das beherrschende virus sein
das was wir jetzt noch als über wegen
des virus haben das wird dann mehr oder
weniger also es wird dann nach und nach
verschwinden
das war das eine aber trotzdem wollte
man eben heute abend unbedingt menschen
motivieren menschen weiter mitnehmen
wieder so schön heißt auch im politiker
innen sprecher indem man eben wieder
hoffnungsschimmer an den horizont malte
sag ich jetzt mal die war ganz schließen
wurde heute abend überhaupt gar nicht
gesprochen angela merkel erwähnte mal
kurz in einem satz
man setze sich freitag zur freitags
zusammen und definiere mutations gebiete
da geht es aber vor allem um die
kommunikation mit den fluggesellschaften
aus welchen ländern man ein fliegen darf
noch deutschland ja da gibt es ja eine
liste von ländern aus denen das im
moment nicht möglich ist
aber über grenzschließungen tschechien
österreich wurde heute nicht gesprochen
dann würde ich gerne die inzidenz in hof
gerade nochmal gegenchecken dazu nutzen
wir noch mal die seite von der zdf-
heute- und sehen hier moment wo ist es
hier ist hof in bayern und der grenze zu
tschechien mit 2 156 fällen je 100.000
einwohner
direkt daneben wunsiedel mit 264 also
ein bisschen drüber und direkt daneben
und das scheint mir dann doch der
spitzenreiter zu sein ist tirschenreuth
mit 393 fällen pro 100.000 einwohner
das heißt tirschenreuth ist sehr sehr
weit entfernt von der perspektive von
unter 35 nicole von der heute gesprochen
wurde dass in diesen landkreisen nicht
nur einzelhandel sondern auch museen
theater kultureinrichtungen wieder
geöffnet werden können
glaubst du dass man mit den zahlen die
du so hasst und mit den vorliegenden
maßnahmen die man so hat dass man
tatsächlich bis ostern realistisch so
weit ist dass all diese branchen wieder
eine perspektive haben schrittweise zu
öffnen oder schon vorher das finde ich
eine wahnsinnig schwierige frage wenn
man jetzt sieht der aktuelle bundesweite
wert liegt bei 68
das findet man ja aus der heutigen
perspektive schon sensationell guten
wert auch hier in berlin wir lagen kurz
vor weihnachten kurz vor der 200 ja da
bin ich überfragt also ich kann nur noch
mal aufzählen welche variablen wichtig
dafür sind dass es funktionieren kann da
geht es einmal darum klappt es
tatsächlich die mutationen möglichst
klein zu halten
halten sich die menschen an die regeln
ja wie läuft es mit dem impfungen
eine frage ist auch diese auch immer
noch ungeklärt was ist mit geimpften
übertragen die das virus trotzdem
möglicherweise weiter an andere wie
entwickelt sich das geschehen in den
schulen wie wird überhaupt in den
schulen und wie wird mit dem schulhof
nungen umgegangen gibt es genug
ausweichmöglichkeiten um sogenannte
kohorten zu bilden also feste gruppen in
den schulen die einander auch nicht
begegnen sondern nur in sich
unterrichtet werden dafür muss wiederum
der digital unterricht dann für die
kinder die zu hause bleiben weiter
ausgestaltet werden da wo er nicht
funktioniert das ist ja anscheinend
abhängig von lehrer zu lehrer
das sind so viele offene fragen
also da würde ich mich selber in eine
lage manövrieren wenn ich jetzt eine
aussage treffen würde
das kann ich nicht man kann das nur
hoffen man kann das noch offen
bevor wir uns an dieser stelle für den
siebten märz verabreden zum nächsten
bund länder treffen die hall eine letzte
frage für heute aus welchen ecken kommt
denn morgen kritik was erwartest du es
wird auf jeden fall kritik kommt von der
fdp die im vorfeld auch schon gesagt hat
wir reden hier über mutanten wir reden
hier über varianten des virus
die zahlenmäßig noch gar nicht hergeben
dass wir weiter im schotter und bleiben
das wird auf jeden fall kommen denn
genau das ist ja heute abend beschlossen
worden und dass die zahlen das noch
nicht hergeben wissen wer alle da wird
ja auch transparent mit argumentiert
also dieser punkt bleibt die afd
fundamental oppositionell wir hatten
heute hier im hauptstadtstudio beatrix
von storch im interview und wer trickst
schon stolz sagt es gibt keine
wissenschaftlichen belege dafür dass die
maßnahmen die in den letzten wochen
ergriffen worden sind überhaupt dafür
verantwortlich sind dass die zahlen
runter gegangen sind da gibt es jetzt
wissenschaftler innen die ihr
widersprechen
aber ich glaube nicht dass die afg von
dieser argumentation bis morgen abrücken
wird davon ist auf jeden fall auszugehen
es wird sicherlich auch
von den grünen kritik kommen die immer
wieder darauf gepocht haben dass der
bundestag beteiligt wird vor allem an
den debatten nun gibt es morgen früher
eine regierungserklärung von angela
merkel
da sagen aber die grünen warum denn erst
nach der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
warum nach den entscheidungen warum
nicht vorher davon ist auszugehen
bei der linken kann ich mir vorstellen
dass die auch noch mal sagen werden naja
also selbsttest woher nehmen wenn nicht
stehlen das geld dafür
wir gehen da eventuell in einer
zwei-klassen-gesellschaft ja wenn der
bänder denn diese frage nicht gelöst
wird und interessant wird ja auch noch
mal sein wie die spd und die union
miteinander umgehen die spd kritisiert
ja seit langem das imb management vor
allem von bundesgesundheitsministerin
spahn cdu
sie sagt das hat mit dem bundestags war
ja nichts zu tun indem wir stecken und
den übrigen wahlen die ansteht das mag
auch sein
unterm strich bleibt es gibt massive
kritik eines koalitionspartners am
anderen koalitionspartner
schauen wir mal wie sich das in den
kommenden wochen entwickelt peter
altmaier hat ja heute angekündigt bis
zum 15
februar würden gelder ausgezahlt das ist
seit heute
heute nachmittag ist es online möglich
das wurde auch mit großen mit großer
zufriedenheit von angela merkel eben in
der pressekonferenz verkündet wenn das
klappt okay aber wenn nicht dürfte da
auch noch mal ärger auf brannten wenn
das doch nicht so läuft wie es sollte in
der vergangenheit war das ja sehr
schwierig also es wird massive kritik
gegen das ist überhaupt keine frage
aus sämtlichen denkbaren richtungen
dankeschön nicole ich muss mich
korrigieren das nächste
bund-länder-treffen ist natürlich nicht
am 17 märz bis dahin soll der
verlängerte schotter und gehen das heißt
man muss sich vorher treffen um zu
vereinbaren wie es dann weitergehen soll
das wäre dann der dritte märz sorry for
that aber man verliert er das gefühl für
raum und zeit in diesen zeiten und damit
möchte ich das gespräch auch gerne
beenden liebe nicole mit einem
kommentar von tobi fliewatüüt über
youtube die inzidenz auf schalke
punktzahl drücken dann aber bitte
lockern
das ist nicht nett aber man muss auch
alles irgendwie mit humor sehen deshalb
herzlichen dank für diesen kommentar
danke für alle anderen kommentare danke
fürs mitmachen
danke nicole schönen abend nach berlin
und schönen abend in allem